от зараз ще підійдемо до людей які тут
перебувають і по поцікавимося власне
чому їх притискала поліція Добрий день
скажіть будь ласка Добрий день скажіть
будь ласка що тут відбувалося чому
поліція всіх людей тиснула поліція
поліція відібрала в нас наше майно
чіпали їм Чомусь я не знаю чи в поліції
немає чи такі саме знадобилися вони в
нас їх відібрали і відібрали жорстоко
силою потоптавши людей тут всякі
слабшеньки стояли ми їх ялів випустили
звідси от така ситуація прийшлося
це провокація і цей репетиція
поліцейські на нашу відповідну реакцію І
як воно дальше буде я думаю це була в
них така маленька репетиція Ну як буде
далі побачимо як вважаєте чому
розпили спецзасоби Ну я не знаю це тоже
поліцейські ті самі люди кажуть
Я думаю що потихеньку потихеньку нас
провіряють більше це була перевірка і чи
ми там будем тоже щось там застосовувати
проти них чи ні Ну ми вийшли на мирну
акцію довгими руками і більш нічого
укажіть навіщо були бочки
для підтримки громади для підтримки духу
нашого робимо таке заохочення барабани
Можна сказати ми не збирались їх тут
палити нічого страшного от я Допустим
мікрофон тоже можна забрати щоб тоді не
не чула вся площа тому що так само ми
використовували бочки Я не знаю чому
вони їм ну я би там не було а наше діло
праве і ми переможемо
ніяких знаків які власне незрозуміло чи
вони працівники поліції чи Хто ці люди і
вони власне говорили такі гасла як
наприклад образи до людей які тут
зібралися і говорили інші неприємні речі
і виникає велике питання А хто ж
насправді ці люди можливо це дійсно
тітушки про яких говорили і якщо це
дійсно були вони то хто насправді от
зараз чоловік показує що розбили йому
годинник так штовхалася поліція А зараз
колеги передаю слово своєму колезі
Антону рудаку
дозволяють робитися ноги коли встає
столиця Я закликаю
ми зараз продовжуємо Київ Ми зараз
продовжуємо знаходитись
[музика]
бачимо тут а зараз яке місце кричать
Київ вставай адже те що сьогодні
відбулося А це як назвали Депутат який
радий що ти звавілля Тому що
постраждалого депутата Київрада
Олександра погребицький який власне
сказав що якийсь сказав чому сьогодні
поранили нову і завтра-напросто черговій
сесії Київради а вони будуть збирати
заяву до суду І власне будуть
укурюватися тими діями які сьогодні
вчинила Національна поліція Ну я зараз
вам прошу показати взагалі що тут
відбувається ми пройдемось трохи а також
постраждав сьогодні нагадаю наш оператор
і Євгенія чаричани і йому сьогодні
просто
хоче
обприскали хімічною речовиною
А ось власне Олександр погребицький
Зараз ми спробуємо в ефірі послухайтесь
майно забрали палицю якою с е-е просто
били на моїх очах учасників війни
інвалідів війни я тільки що
начальником поліції під ноги кинув
просто я викликаю це моя звернення до
міністра внутрішніх справ моє як
депутата Київради як заступника голови
фракції європейська Солідарність киї
вської Русі начальник поліції міста
[музика]
Києва
міністр МВД має бути там сам запитувати
декілька підставах співробітники поліції
учасники війни інвалідні війни палицю я
їхню передачу
на третьому
чи добре вчинки падати вони на них
Зайшов вже що там далеко в країні
що випив перетворили країну от
Хаят це ви так показуєте отаке отака В
нас країна така в нас влада
А хто віддав наказ Зеленський А хто може
віддати наказ зараз кому завгодно хто
керує країною хто керує парламентом хто
керує міністерством пан Зеленського і
його шукаєте Скажіть будь ласка
[музика]
люди були цілі бо я як Депутат який
врази щоб Кияни були ці режими увагу
Я навіть боюся у мене там під штанах
[музика]
ви можете тоді буде багато тисяч гривень
після того що чинить е-е поліція Кияни
Всі підтянуться сюди
кілька
матеріалів нашим бортам озброєнь Я думаю
що пояснив чому матеріали тому що
по-перше люди прийдуть захищати
демократію в Україні будуть захищати
люди
тому що те що роблять робітники поліції
це називається узурпація це називається
що коли поліція ті хто присягають народ
проти
учасників війни захищають власний народ
ний депутат України
називається Україна почали Олександра
погребицького А ось
речами
постраждав але як бачимо в нього зараз
немає бажання з нами говорити
дійсно складна ситуація сьогодні сталась
Ну як бачимо тут вже люди прошу показати
оператора піднімають плакати вже
почалася акція а руки геть від Порошенка
ні репресіям політичним І власне ось
поки що тут більш-менш ситуація спокійна
бачимо що збирається в певна горі
журналісти а і зараз штовханина на
якийсь час припинилася і будемо
сподіватися що тут буде все нормально а
з іншого боку вам також вже сходяться і
депутати відеоролитарності сходять і
разом з ними теж стоїть кордон поліції
тож поки що з бачимо тут така картина
також навіть плакати починають
розвішувати вже навіть на самій
будівництві суду а-а
[музика]
прошу оператора показати написано з
геймови тобто що гра для Зеленського Вже
закінчилася
як бачимо
події що відбуваються в демократичній
Україні коли нападають на журналістів на
операторів на тих хто просто прийшов на
мирну акцію в підтримку п'ятого
президента України і власне люди тут це
називається віллям і ще раз нагадаю що
завтра Київрада збирається на
позачергову сесію де будуть власне
обговорювати те що сьогодні те що
сьогодні тут трапилось як бачимо також є
рух по вулиці а і ситуація зараз ще поки
що залишається
скажемо так під контролем тож поки що
передаю слово до студії ми будемо далі
спостерігати за тим що тут відбувається
відразу ж вам вам повідомляти
бо зараз бачимо що люди підходять ближче
сум
ситуація що зараз пропускає поки машини
але імовірно що площа буде найближчим
часом зайнята і ми бачимо що всі люди
підходять до суду власне про це попросив
ведучий в організатор який тут нині
перебуває і знаємо що через годину і 10
хвилин має у Печерському районному суді
міста Києва розпочатися засідання
Слава Україні
уже починає комунальний транспорт і
музикальні рішення починають цю машину
поліцію
екстрена допомога ми пропускаємо
транспортним багато насправді
зокрема вже робоча захисника газу є або
страждання оператора телефону
[музика]
комунального транспорту не забуваємо
навіть також не забувайте про те що
може бути і ми зараз попитаємо у людей
які сюди прийшли
Добрий день ви в прямому ефірі Скажіть
будь ласка як ви спри те що ви сьогодні
тут побачили як поліція штовхала людей
для мене це однозначно повернення
13-14-й рік ці чорні шоломи всі ми
пам'ятаємо 10 грудня коли стояла стіна з
чорним шолом це було чорне зараз також
це ніякої гідності як сказав Правильно
свято не не Національна гвардія це
російська Нацгвардія тому що так
поліцейський чинити з народом не можуть
це Мирна акція ми маємо на це право не
відбувалась нічого проти закону все було
в порядку правоохові
люди всі піднесені не бажаючи нікому
абсолютно зла єдине що я думаю в цій
ситуації саме правильно зробити якби
Зеленський зараз сказав що я помилився
потрібно прокурорам сказати що ми все це
нормально
суддя ми несе скасує все
і скажу що все окей Якщо те що зараз
спілкується Тому це однозначно
повернення
ви сьогодні одяглися ми бачимо такий шар
який нагадує часи Євромайдану і мабуть
не просто так тому що ми побачили які
сьогодні мабуть хочу речі цей шалик він
Євромайдану краматорського з грудня
13-го року коли ми все до Краматорську
збиралися на Євромайдану і це зараз
відстояти свої цінності коли ми
рухаємось в Європу чи в Росії Зеленський
- це відкат повністю всі п'ять років
відкатились і ми і ми зараз в напрямок
зовсім
інше А з Порошенком ви завжди Європа нас
запрошувала завжди
Я дивлюсь закордоном пишалися України
зараз Зеленський церковністю на невиці
Дякуємо вам дуже от почули які нині
думки у людей
з тим що було у
2013-2014 році а я ж передаю слово своїй
колезі Юлії вітовій
так так так
друзі ми зараз знаходимося Під самим
печерським судом Як ви буде чути Зараз
люди скандують скандують ганьба
людей тут справді дуже-дуже-дуже багато
мені Навіть здається що вже і рух
транспорту перекрили тому що ми зараз
вільно я вільно особисто ходжу по дорозі
тут справді багато людей багато працює
журналістів наш оператор постраждав тому
що були такі скажімо бійки і кажуть що
провокують їх саме правоохоронні органи
Зараз ми будемо спостерігати що тут
відбувається чуємо
сирену тут
що наразі Все спокійно
ніхто все здається Поки що тихо
[музика]
А зараз я хочу передати слово нашій
Вікторії Максимові яка знаходиться теж у
центрі всіх подій Вікторія передаю тобі
слово
[музика]
вітаю вітаю ще раз І от зараз поруч зі
мною знаходиться депутатка Київської
міської ради представниця партії
європейська Солідарність Дінара
хобібулаєва пані дінаров Що відбулося як
оцінюєте те що сьогодні побачили
Слухайте Я коли приїхала я була просто в
шоці тому що мене Мені це нагадало
знаєте там кінець 2013 року коли просто
люди прийшли
зібралися звісно є справа громад я
солідальна молодь яка підготувала там
намети чай для людей тому що минулого
разу нас тримало тут до 23 години і
треба було якось зігріватись звісно а Ми
піклуємось за тих громадян які свідомі
які виходять на вулицю тому звісно були
підготовлені там гарячі напої але на
жаль поліція вирішила просто варварським
таким способом все це зламати по-перше
зламали палатки справи громад по-друге
вкрали діжки це взагалі просто шок Чому
Тому що
діжки були зазначені До речі
повідомлення Київський міський державні
адміністрації про те що це буде
використовуватися як музичний інструмент
з підтримкою людей тому що ви бачили як
було холодно хотілося хоч знаєте якогось
якогось підтримки звісно тут було
зазначено що буде екран що буде
повністю звукове обладнання що буде
гарячий чай тобто все це було зазначено
заздалегідь повідомлення але коли
поліція просто почала розкидувати людей
люди падали там пару жіночих До речі
були поранені тому що Звісно палатка
тільки
виставили і там десь були гострі края
тому подібне тобто тому мені здається що
Зеленський вже переходить всі червоні
лінії тому що видно що люди по-перше
правоохоронні органи виконують наказ і
накази в них такий що просто все ЗМІ
роботи і налякати людей звісно люди які
підходять і бачать що тут замес
починають якось знаєте дивно на це
дивитися але це не це стосується тих
патріотів які сюди прийшли не тільки
заради Порошенка А зараз до того аби в
Україні все ж таки була справедлива
правоохоронна система судова система щоб
поліція була на боці людей а не на
Клякса пані зі нав'язане з цим візитом
така сьогодні агресія правоохоронців до
людей ви знаєте мені здається Вони
намагаються
викликати і в нас агресію знаєте
показати нас такої сторони що начебто Ми
нападаємо на когось я бачила вже в
каналах банкової що Вони намагаються
просто викривити цю ситуацію і показати
що ми агресивні але це Мирна акція це
акція захисту демократії і
захисту прав і свобод в першу чергу тому
що кожен з нас має право вийти на вулицю
і підтримати того кого він хоче
підтримувати але такі дії з боку поліції
показують що вони налаштовані дуже
агресивно до людей Поліція має бути з
народом тому здається Вони намагаються
виправити цю ситуацію але в них не вийде
люди підтягуються як ви бачите люди
йдуть і в соціальних мережах знаєте
стріми ведуться тобто видно хто є хто
тому на сьогоднішній день е-е Наша
задача - це провести мирно акцію і не
дозволити провокаціям бути Дякую вам
мали можливість поспілкуватися наживо з
бінарною гати буваєвою депутаткою
Київської міської ради із фракції
європейська Солідарність спостерігаємо
далі а я продаю колезі своїй я ні
проняній слово
є
а великим благословенням Зараз ми
знаходимося поблизу
рівно години залишається до початку
засідання по справі Петра Порошенка і
вже зараз почалися тут поблизу
Печерського суду сутички та провокації з
боку правоохоронців покус у мене
знаходиться учасник російського
Київської війни блогер Олексій Петров
Добрий день Олексію розкажіть чи бачили
Чи були ви там по цьому осередку цих
сутичок що взагалі відбулося І взагалі
цю відбулися ці сутички на вашу думку
чому зараз ці провокації йдуть з боку
поліції з боку правоохоронців які мають
бути власне
[музика]
приказ для того чтобы создавать
провокации Почему Потому что это не
первая акция нецера они десятая которая
понимает участь
аби показати що відбувається Просто
зараз була
воюють військові які виконують такі
воюють на сході які виконують свої
завдання поставлені завдання на сході
але я бачив також поведінку
прикордонників працівників митного
контролю
які намагалися Петра Олексійовича
затримати
штучно створювали всі умови для цього
забрали паспорт що народило мем паспорт
Порошенка
Та все ж
і Петро Олексійович з командою і ми
разом з вами ми в той день позавчора в
понеділок 17 січня ми були єдиною
стороною яка все зробила по закону і
вчасно
Ми вчасно встигли на засідання але як ви
знаєте що засідання було призначене на
Героїв початок слухання на 11:00
суддя прийшов в 11:40
ми собі то можемо приблизно зрозуміти
чому саме так сталося тому що
ні суддя ні на банковій ні прокурор
ська вони не розраховували на те що
порох встигне вони не розраховували на
те
вони свято вірили що він А Перший
варіант або
неполуги варіант прикордонникам вдасться
його затримати третій варіант дбрівців
вдасться його затримати і він приїде не
вчасно ці всі плани провалилися ці всі
плани провалилися і ми вийшли
підтримати правду ми проти брехні чи не
так друзі
ми проти брехні Ми хочемо жити чесно Ми
хочемо жити щасливо Ми хочемо жити
Спокійно ми хочемо жити не озираючись
довкола через страх чи острах
Ми хочемо збиратися на наші Великодні
мітинги акції Ми хочемо зустрічати з
великим товариством і хочемо розуміти що
наша поліція українська поліція буде
оберігати нас а не бити не обкрадати
в нас на жаль забрали якщо я якщо я
правильно зрозумів то у нас забрали
бутерброди
хлопці смачного вам
вони пригодяться у нас забрали бочки
я принаймні бачу до так смішно виглядало
коли четверо хлопців ну в чорній формі
Вони біжать з тою бочкою вони
шпортаються падають але вперто біжать
тому що дано наказ вкрасти одну бочку Та
ми вам ще одну подаруємо ми вам три
бочки подаруємо хочете 10 ми вам
дамо та Підійдіть скажіть дайте нам
бочку Я не зовсім розумію правда Для
чого вам бочки Ну нам зрозуміло для чого
ми їх брали сюди як
музичні інструменти про що Ми
попереджали працівників поліції ми то я
маю на увазі оргкомітет організаторів
цієї акції Ми попереджали працівників
поліції Ми попереджали Головне
управління що у нас будуть бочки як у
музичні інструменти як у барабани Все
буде цивілізовано Все буде спокійно якщо
хлопці Якщо вам потрібна бочка Підійдіть
і скажіть по-людськи ми ж всі люди
Підійдіть
Дайте будь ласка бочку та що нам шкода
бочки Друзі Та нам не шкода бочки
вам сильно заважав вогонь нема питань ми
його загасили хоча вогонь Ми розпалювали
в печах які спеціально сконструйовані
таким чином що
[музика]
мені вперто дзвонить
ці перші спеціально сконструйовані таким
чином що немає до довколишнього
середовища доступу вільного вогню от
немає
це нашим
правоохоронцям правдоборцям це не
сподобалося підійшли сказали типу гасіть
вогонь це не погоджено
Окей я собі згадую друзі 14-й рік ми
питалися в когось дозволу Чи ми можемо
полити вогонь в бочках
Мені здається що мені в кого дозволу не
питали
і
розуміючи те що хлопці десь також Ну
вони виконують накази ми загасили вогонь
але їм це також не сподобалось
недостатньо сильно ми його загасили і
вони прийшли і почали вчиняти провокації
я насамперед Я зараз хочу подякувати от
щиро і чесно я хочу подякувати поліції
за те що вони провокації припинили
то багато чого
Я розумію що їм буде прилітати по шапці
тому що вони не до кінця виконали наказ
але я я щиро хочу їм подякувати за те що
вони припинили провокації
ми це оцінили
[музика]
залишайтеся людьми хлопці і дівчата
виносити чорну форму поліції
незважаючи Які у вас погони незважаючи
яка кількість рацій у вас залишайтеся
людьми
тому що ви людьми родилися
[музика]
пишайтеся людьми
щоб ви в гробу своєму не переверталися
ми помремо рано чи пізно це є безперечно
це доказаний факт що ніхто не жив вічно
робіть все так щоб вас не проклинали
будьте людьми
маєте запитання Підійдіть і запитайте не
треба наганяти 100-150 Космонавтів які
будуть бити жінок які будуть ламати руки
[музика]
зараз хочу дати слово Олександру
погребинському депутат Київської міської
ради заступник голови організації
громадської Брати по зброї
Слава нації
як мене чутно
сьогодні влада
в обличчі
тітушні у формі співробітників поліції
перейшла межу
коли космонавти атакують
учасників війни щоб зламати палатки
громадських організацій і партії
європейська Солідарність це значить що
влада перейшла межу
від нині для них громадяни України є
ворогами
на мої заклики перестати безлад заклики
учасника війни
заклики депутата Київради заклики
заступника голови фракції європейська
Солідарність
Вони почали бити
інвалідів війни збивати з них жінок
мені травмували ногу і прямо зараз Я
викликав поліцію і швидку для того щоб
зафіксувати Цей факт
я викликаю начальника поліції пана
вигівського який знаходиться прям тут
[музика]
в залу Київської міської ради на
позачергову сесію
на 11:00
[музика]
Він має пояснити дії своїх посіпак які
вважають що давай даючи присягу
українському народу його можна бити
даючи присягу тим хто захищає їх захищає
їхні сім'ї на лінії фронту їх можна бити
Але я вам скажу абсолютно точно ні
фракція європейської Солідарності в
київраді
ні народ України ні Кияни вам цього не
дозволять
я буду робити все можливе в рамках своїх
повноважень як громадянин як депутат для
того щоб всі хто сьогодні мав
приймав участь у цьому безладі понесли
покарання ви перейшли всі межі Я
закликаю всіх киян сьогодні бути тут
якщо ми не Захистимо свої права на
свободу слова зібрання і право говорити
вони задушать нас всіх
Я закликаю всіх учасників війни сьогодні
бути тут адже тут сьогодні
б'ють ваших побратимів і послуг
Слава нації
Чи ви підтримуєте в моїй вимоги
Я не чую
гуртуємось і ми точно переможемо ніколи
Слава нації
наша перемога є за нами
Ми йдемо з вірою в серці
Ми йдемо з твердою вірою і
надію на плече побратима і посести нас
стає більше нас є вся Україна ми є народ
ми є
[музика]
владодавцем ми є законодавцем ми є судом
ми є прокурорами ми є адвокатами ми є
суддями
Ми народ Ми нація
інакше бути не можна і це право
називатись нацією
[музика]
сьогодні пороха Завтра прийдуть по
когось з нами України
головні убори з чоловікам
[музика]
українець Слава нації Україна
Україна
[оплески]
[музика]
Путін
брати і сестри зараз даю слово
Володимиру в'ятровичу
[музика]
Всім привіт
знову нікого нема
знову порожня площа
є хтось
Давайте так щоб почули що справді сусід
за цими товстими стінами почули що ми їм
бажаємо що вони мають почути від нас га
й
трохи далі звідси знаходиться парламент
урядовий квартал уряд давайте щоб вони
почули разом
[оплески]
і нарешті на одному з Київських горбиків
на вулиці банковій є маленький
переляканий чоловічок який скучив за
нашим
[оплески]
друзі Я дуже дякую вам що ви знову тут Я
дуже дякую вам що виходячи на ці сходи я
бачу тисячі очей Я відчуваю енергію тих
людей які готові відстояти Україну Який
він стоїть готовий відходити демократію
після того що було два дні тому тих 12
годин знущання ми все одно стоїмо ми тут
щоб показати що ми разом що ми Захистимо
Україну Незалежності
шановні правоохоронці
саме на вас відповідальність в тому щоб
сьогоднішня акція прошла мирну тихо і
спокійно саме цього ми хочемо ми тут для
того щоб показати своє незадоволеннями
спробами переслідування опозиції ми
очікуємо від вас дій виключно в
правовому полі звертається до
керівництва київської поліції Не
дозволяйте провокацій треба бочки
подаруємо після акції без проблем навіть
підпишемо кожен бочку правда
шановні правоохоронці Ось я сподіваюся
що з вашого боку більше не буде такого
роду провокацій і акція пройде мирно Я
хотів би так само звернутися до вищого
керівництва держави
знайдіть собі сили підніміть голову
поверніть її
[музика]
нас єдині тут нема ворога порох не ворог
Подивіться на Схід
поверніть її погляд до нас і скажіть що
зараз не час для якихось суперечок зараз
час з'єднатися зараз час ліктем до
лікаря стояти для того щоб зупинити
Московську орду яка кожної миті може
вторгнутися в Україну це те що ми маємо
почути від вас як Верховного
головнокомандувача Ви любите цей це
звання ви ви його на на Це треба
згадували у своєму інтерв'ю Покажіть що
у верховна головнокомандувача об'єднайте
Україну об'єднайте Україну для того щоб
потім зрозумів сюди не можна лізти не
лізь уб'є у
чекати
на неї України це ваше завдання як
президента країни це
ваша родича об'єднувати країну саме
об'єднана країна зможе об'єднати довкола
себе світ саме таку об'єднану країну
представив світові Порошенко
коли не було армії ми її створили коли
не було дипломатичної підтримки би її
створили світ побачив Україну яка готова
боротися світ побачив Україну яка готова
чинити спроби і чинила спротив світ
виявив готовність захищати таку Україну
саме це ми повинні показати сьогодні
сьогодні
в Україні американський високопосадовець
представник Сполучених Штатів Америки
пан блінкен Він має побачити єдину
Україну готову боротися Він має побачити
єдність в країні натомість він бачить
абсурдні спроби переслідувати опозиції Я
думаю я історик і історія свідчить що
Україна з'явилася завдяки тому що ми
об'єднали дві речі свою боротьбу за
свободу незалежність своєю боротьбою за
демократію Україна в стоє тільки як
демократична держава тому сьогодні
захищаючи цю демократію ми чекаємо не
тільки Порошенка ми захищаємо тільки
опозиція ми захищаємо і українську
незалежність ми не дамо тут в країні
появитися якомусь маленькому Путіну який
відкриє ворота Путіну іншому ми цього не
допустимо ми відстояємо незалежність ми
відстоїмо демократію тому що разом
ще раз дуже дякую всім дуже Дякую усім
знаєте справді спогади сьогоднішнього
дня Це спогади очевидно з 2014 року коли
нам було важко коли нам було холодно
коли нам було мокро але ми встояли ми
побачили
унікальне богоявлення 2014 року тому що
Бог був з нами і ми перемогли тому що
Бог був з нами тоді все виглядає
абсолютно безнадійно в нас було не так
багато Влада була набагато сильнішою але
ми вірили і ми перемогли і Влада впала Я
впевнений що так буде І тепер Я
впевнений що ми відстоюємо демократія
всередині країни Я впевнений що ми
відстоюємо незалежність своєї країни
допоки будемо вірити вірити в те що ми
робимо те що ми робимо є правдою а воно
є правдою Дякую кожному з вас і давайте
згадаємо як тоді коли на Майдані було
важко бо один одного підтримували
кричалкою сто їм
хто Діма стой
[музика]
мо їмо стоїмо
дякую ще раз кожному з вас і стоїмо за
те щоб нам не було соромно дивитися Віті
своїм дітям Слава Україні
шановне товариство маленькі
организаційне оголошення ви пам'ятаєте я
говорив про тітушок які збираються біля
Хмельницького вже близько 60 людей
перемістилося до нашого товариства тобто
Будьте пильними будьте уважними вони
концентруються здебільшого в районі
наметів але не виключено що частина з
них розсіялася поміж нас Будьте пильними
будьте уважними між нами є тітушня
звертаюся до них же до тітушні
пацани подумайте Чи вам воно треба
подумайте чи 200 там 1,000 грн що воно
варто побити хребет е-е і Ну я про
совість не буду згадувати тому що
совісті У вас немає ви ж її продаєте
ваша ціна 1,000 грн максимум
500 грн може бути хто Як хто крупніший
1,000 грн хто менше 500 грн там напевно
Там напевно на кілограми йде оплата а-а
друзі брати і сестри Будьмо уважні
фіксуйте Всі якісь незрозумілі рухи
Передавайте інформацію братам по зброї
та нашим волонтерам справи громад
шановні чи не шановні тітушки Ми ваші
переміщення бачимо ми фіксуємо ми знаємо
Де Ви знаходитесь тому подумайте Чи вам
воно потрібно
чи результат вартий тієї там 500 грн чи
1000 грн подумайте про це
шановні друзі Я маю велику честь
представити зараз людину яка наближала
нашу незалежність в кінці 80-х на
початку 90-х років людину яку можна
назвати одним з оцих засновників
української незалежності Ярослав кендер
саме один з тих депутатів як завдяки
яким Україна стала незалежною в 91-му
році поаплодуємо подякуємо
шановні друзі
[музика]
шановні брати і сестри знаєте я давно не
виступав на таких
зібраннях українських патріотів
я почну з того що якби були сьогодні
живими
світлої пам'яті В'ячеслав Чорновіл
Михайло Горинь Левко Лук'яненко і
багато-багато інших тих з когорти
шістдесятників які за ідею незалежної
української держави відбули
багато років у мордовських
комуністичних концтаборах вони б ці люди
сьогодні були Тут поруч з нами поруч з
нами
і я попросив слова для того щоб
ну проживши
не коротке уже з життя і
спостерігаючи все що твориться у нашій
уже незалежній українській державі Я
ніби телепортуюся десь на 50 років назад
бо я і моє покоління і мої побратими
яких я називав і ще сотні інших ми щось
подібне пережили у
65-66 роках
72-73 потім 80-х роках коли
чекісти за дорученням цієї кривавої
компартії робили оці повальні погроми
арештовуючи проводячи обшуки знищуються
все що нагадувала про Україну про
українську мову про українську традицію
і таке інше
і тому сьогодні я пригадую коли на
політичних процесах у Львові в
івано-франківську у Києві
судили тих людей яких я називав
шістдесятників їм також
визначали тодішні судді
тодішні прокурори зраду
антирадянську діяльність що означала
зрада радянської батьківщини була
[музика]
лагідніша стаття так звана 187 за образу
честі гідності за вияв так би мовити
інформацію яка ганьбить радянську
державу тобто за анекдота за необережне
слово про Україну про бажання мати свою
Україну Ви отримували відповідний
відповідний термін і сьогодні
інкримінувати
людині яка за свої 5 років роботи на
посаді президента України Петру
олексійовичу Порошенку
висувати
звинувачення у зраді ну це те саме що
Чорновола судити за
Ну
за зраду Я знаю України хочу країна була
у складі коли людина за ідею
Незалежності відсиділа 15 років
мордовських тюремні таборів одним словом
це настільки безглузде звинувачення і я
спостерігаючи всі події від понеділка
18-го числа і
дивлячись як
Банкова на чолі з Зеленчук тим так
званим президентом реалізовує оцей
сценарій який вони виписали для того
щоби уже натрапили така накласти на руки
Петра Олексійовича кайданки і завести
його в суд і так дальше і прив'язати до
медведчука це людина яка у час
війни України із ненажерним кремлем
Москвою
рятувала в цій страшно важкі складні
роки
врятувала Україну і навпаки Україна у
цей важкий час От ти отримала певний
Стимул і можливість розвиватися бо
тільки декілька тих конкретних справ які
за допомогою Петра Олексійовича були
зреалізовані а особливо отця
Трійця на якій тримається який є
фундаментом України Віра мова армія Без
віри не буває народу це без роду плени
без роду племені який з натовп який десь
там в якомусь куточку земної кулі живе
Без мови немає народу і немає держави
без армії
головного охоронця кожної держави в якій
вона існує також немає держави
Порошенко - це створив і слава богу якби
Порошенко я свято переконаний маючи
певний життєвий і політичний досвід адже
у Верховній Раді я пропрацював перших
шість каденцій Слава Богу хочеш чи не
хочеш навчишся дуже багато чого і якби
так
сталося коли Б наш ну важко б я
остерігаюся якесь криве слово про
частину нашого українського народу який
обрав оце непорозуміння оцю плісняву
зелену яка яка корозією стала на тілі
нашої держави тих 73% яких уже ясна річ
давно немає але вони ввели нашу державу
своїми руками у цей стан який маємо
сьогодні так якби цього не сталося І ми
мали ще п'ять років
президентства Порошенка є свято
переконаний що Україна була би вже на
крок до
НАТО вона була б рукою подати до повного
членства в Європейському Союзі Україна
ви сьогодні була найкращим другом усіх
європейських і світових лідерів І
завершуючи хочу сказати що сьогодні
найлютішими ворогами України
суб'єкти є Російська Федерація і є
Банкова якби Адже всі лідери світу
лідери провідних держав а більше ніж ми
знаємо що таке офіс президента - це
кубло фсбшне тут на банковій біля
Верховної Ради от Вони знають всі ці
зв'язки фсбшників з банкової із ФСБ яке
розміщене у Москві і вони знають всі Ці
зв'язки і тому ніхто не хоче особливо
розмовляти із цією командою тому що
знають поділитися
інформацією секретною завтра знатиме
Москва але з другого боку ці лідери
розуміють що віддати Україну на потолу
Москві це зміцнити Московську імпе і
тому вони не зважаючи ні на що за таке
допомагають Україні і Я переконаний що
не залишить Україну одним словом
допомогти побороти в першу чергу ворога
на банковій це наша справа наших груп
Тут ніхто нам допомагати не буде це наше
право громадянське бо ми є влада
український народ була зроблена помилка
ми її мусимо виправити шановні друзі Я
безмежно Дякую що от з кожною хвилиною
бачу збільшується збільшується кількість
людей і вірю в те що сьогодні Петро
Олексійович вийде із цієї зали у
і ми всі почуємо інформацію що справа
яку йому безпардонно
безпідставно так би мовити інкримінують
абсолютно розвалилася там немає нічого
по суті звинувачення у цьому
звинуваченні Ми переможемо це 100%, якщо
не сьогодні то завтра якщо не завтра то
у найближчий час Україна буде Україна
понад усе Слава Україні
Дякую вам
[музика]
що сьогодні було
і поліції
яку влаштували начебто тут люди не мирні
начебто радикали це все брехня абсолютно
Мирний протест абсолютно мирні люди
вчора мене був ефір зі слугою народа він
розповідав що хтось йому сказав що тут є
люди ці зброю я кажу якщо вони є
арештовують тих чого ви Чим ви
займаєтесь ви ж маєте відповідаєте за
безпеку тут нема людей ані з грою Ані
агресивних тут є люди чи я зброя це
любов до України Це є наша зброя чи є
зброя це наше гідність яка не
дозволить це є наша зброя і ці зброї
вони насправді бояться
а все може бути Мені здається що це
ганьба те що наші західні партнери які
їдуть підтримати боротьбу України за
себе бачить що Зеленський розколює
суспільство
роз'єднує суспільство атакує патріотичну
частину суспільства Я не знаю як їм це
можна пояснити і це дуже шкода 25
почнеться засідання у справі Петра
Порошенка Які ваші передбачення з
приводу рішення як вважаєте що може
відбутися я не буду робити прогноз якщо
за законом цей треш мають повернути
прокурора заберіть це геть якщо а-а за
дзвінком з банкової то може бути що
завгодно тому ми тут Тому ми боремося і
ми будемо боротися чому су
ддя форум людей Вони сподівалися що
розійдуться люди до ночі і тоді вони
заарештують Порошенка коли вони
попереду зійшлися
скільки людей зараз тут
це до речі наш депутат міської ради
Одеси наш кандидат був мера Одеси від
європейської солідарності Петро Обухов
давайте поспілкуємося з вами Скажіть
будь ласка як ви сприймаєте те що
сьогодні тут побачили це це звертання
демократії Ми повинні цього не допустити
нормальних країнах ось коли Трамп став
президентом
змінність влади я демократія його
розвиток економіки якщо в нас будуть
страждати президентів просто так тому що
це комусь не подобається то в нас буде
погано економікою погане буде для всіх і
навіть для виборців Зеленського і ми
повинні цього не допустити дякую вам
дуже
знову українці
[музика]
з нас на жаль не президент а президент
Росії президент а президент Російської
Федерації
Україна капітулювала
[музика]
2019 році
пообіцявши все а не зробивши нічого
Він зараз чіпляється своїми скрученими
від корупції
намагаючись закрити голос опозиції
заблокувати бізнес змусити
треба виживати а не перемагати
але Ми нація переможців ми перемогли не
одну імперію і вистояли не під час
однієї тому переможемо і цього разу
і ще боявся що Порошенко не повернеться
Порошенко повернувся бо він лідер
України і він знає що за Україну варто
боротися
Зеленський весь час переконував що ніхто
не вийде Подивіться на це площу тут
тисячі людей які вийшли і будуть
виходити до тих пір поки Зеленський
президент бо це не президент а президент
і я вірю що ми неодмінно переможемо що
ми зупинимося дикого каналів
некомпендентності друзів олігархів
безконечного корупції Бо Україна повинна
мати шанс на нормальну сильну заможну
успішну державу Де кожен українець
пишається тим що він громадянин
центру Східної Європи а не вічне резерв
для когось ресурсів людської сили і
інтелекту
подивиться скільки українці стали
успішними по всьому світу а не успішними
тільки в Україні тому що Україна без
конечно грабують безконечного шокують і
безконечно використовують Ми повинні це
зупинити раз і назавжди Ми повинні
перемогти в цій вій
ні проти Федерації
мати спокій
[музика]
но агентів Кремля на банку чи на
Грушевського а успішних
[музика]
українців на буковелях і селах а Вест
держав вперед Дякую що ви прийшли Дякую
що ми разом Ми переможемо
[музика]
Разом до перемоги разом до перемоги
так чи інакше перемога Буде за нами Я не
втомлюсь це повторювати тому що я свято
вірю і знаю В те що ми є з правдою в
наших серцях наших душах живе правда а
де Правда там і Бог Бог є з нами не
втрачаємо віри ми вміємо перемагати ми
знаємо як це робити нас цього не навчали
в університетах А це і ніде не будуть
навчати Ми мали з тим народитися і ми з
цим народилися недурно говорять що ми з
вами є козацького роду козаки і козачки
і то не якийсь рафіновані козаки в
оксамитових шароварах і в чистеньких
вишиванках дзвінкими шабельками то є
рафіновані козаки ми є справжні козаки і
козачки тому що було скоро перемога Буде
за нами тому що це не просто посадити
Порошенка
вірять з яким радяться
а закрити лідером опозиції це означає
побудувати авторитарний режим побудувати
диктатуру
Так я бачу що наближається аби до
Олексійович Порошенко
[музика]
давай жарко хорошо
Україна зустрічає лідера об'єднаної
позиції Петро Олексійовича Порошенка
доброго Олексійовича ми з вами
[музика]
був врятували Україну разом зі всім
українським народом від [__]
ської нашому Вам сьогодні
друзі брати і сестри сьогодні зранку
почались провокації
і щоб не було
провокаційні потрібні
[музика]
Порошенко
хрещається
в річці Йордан
Слава Ісусу Христу
[музика]
Сьогодні
велика церковне свято
і багато з тих тисяч людей які сьогодні
знову
зібрали вони
знову зібралися для того щоб боротися за
демократіями в Україні
за наш впевнений рух
Європейський союз та НАТО
Бо саме за це Сьогодні ми тут боремося
цей ранок почали
на частина разом зі мною Мариною
михайлівською золотоверхом
[музика]
скажи мені святкували отримання томосу
вони
за це порушили проти мене справу
так само як і за наказ
переходу українських збройних сил
Контрнаступ справа проти Порошенка
[музика]
а наказ
ка Азовське море
Порошенко
хто
наказ за підписання і створення
нормандського формату угода про
асоціацію
вони ненавидять нас
А з чим це пов'язана така ненависть до
України і до нас з вами
аж допоки мене не підсказали
[музика]
під на це питання українські військові
вже
і розумне твердження
скажуть на фронті десертиви
[музика]
більше ніж ворога не навіть своїх
бойових товаришів
як але свій страх і пішли в атаку
вони ненавидять нас за свої страхи
твердо
до перестають у воріт
[музика]
значна частина відповідальності лягає на
нас з вами
на нас з вами які мають
що є
силу України бо тільки сильно України
разом з міжнародною коаліцією здати
подивитися
як пройшов позавчорашній день коли
десятки тисяч людей зібралися на мітинг
Вони злякалися вони збиралися
заарештувати мене або не пустити в
Україну злякалися
вони збиралися не дати проїхати до суду
злякалися а потім Вони злякалися
[музика]
що вони відчули що щось сюди пішло не
так
зверніть увагу вчора
46 шкіл Києва була закрита
із-замінування
[музика]
діти на холоді стояли на вулиці
вони когось знайшли
і
вчора були заміновані станції метро
можливо
російськими
провокаторами диверсантами люди вони
позбавлені можливості в Києві
користуватися метро вони когось знайшли
ні
було зупинено робота промислових
підприємств була відключена
електроенергія вони когось знайшли ні
чому бо вони полюють за нами з вами вони
всі сили поліції кинули на протидію нам
бо нас вони бояться А Путіна
чекай
І от ми маємо зупинити цей процес ми з
вами і тому у нас дуже важливе місце
подивитися Сьогодні світить сонечко нам
вже легше ніж позавчора
нас зібралися не менше ніж позавчора і
ми всі готові боротися за Україну
ми будемо боротися і ми обов'язково
переможемо
щойно прямо перед цим
Парламентська група асоціації
Європейського парламенту прийняла
спеціальну заяву на підтримку Порошенка
на нашу з вами підтримку європарламент
нічого не нагадує
13-й рік так само я озвучував 13-му році
вітання і підтримку наших європейських
партнерів сьогодні Ранок почався з того
Ні не поліція
Беркут застосувала ебонітами палички
Зеленського для того щоб бити ветеранів
нічого не нагадую
Януковичу сьогодні зранку
за наказом
псевдо-учасника Майдану Монастирського
Монастирський Ти для того ходив на
Майдан 13-14 щоб сьогодні поліція била
ветеранів для того щоб вони зносили
бочки для тої люди поставили для того
щоб погрітися і попити чаю в що ми
перетворилися і тому наша з вами місія
не дати
перетворити Україну в малоросію
новоросію часів Януковича ми це з вами
зробили в 14-му зробимо цей зараз
наша з вами місія не дати
владі Зеленського
перетворитися і забрати найгірше
традиції
Януковича для перетворення країни
ерзат Росії
наше з вами зобов'язань
об'єднати суспільство Якщо це не може
зробити
влада це наш з вами хрест
відстояти зараз демократію
дати по рукам тим хто застосовує
селекти вчастість вибіркове правосуддя
руйнує верховенство права
відновлення телефонне право бо я Собі
уявляю як з офісу президента Зеленський
дав доручення обірвати телефони для того
щоб отримати гарантований результат
але Україна не Росія і ми не росіяни і
він не Путін ми знаємо І демонстрували
як це боротися в четвертому роках ми
знали як це робити в 13-14 роках і
знаємо як це робити зараз
і наша справа все зробити щоб ви не
повторити
13-й рік коли Зеленський виступав на
заказних корпоративах
бабки олігархів Януковича і Путіна А ми
з вами ховали михайлівську золотоверхому
українських героїв які віддали своє
життя за майбутнє України наш з вами
святий обов'язок
пам'ять перед ними зробити все можливе
щоб це було не дарма і ми це зробимо і
ми переможемо Я вірю в це і для цього я
йду на це судилище для нашої з вами
перемоги перемоги України Слава Україні
і велика подяка кожному з вас за
небайдужість тримайтеся і йдемо вперед і
ми переможемо дякую
[музика]
[оплески]
вам брати і сестри за
за те що ви сьогодні є тут тільки разом
разом разом разом разом ми зможемо
перемогти і маючи такого лідера
об'єднаної опозиції
точно перемога Буде за нами Володимира
народний депутат України партія
європейська Солідарність
Слава Україні
[музика]
А ще раз так щоб до банкові почули Слава
Україні
[оплески]
бо вони щось недочувають вони не чують
громадян якщо Зеленський із 30 останніх
днів Лише кілька днів провів на роботі
то це свідчить хто у нас сьогодні
замість президента України це
непорозуміння яке сталося у 2019 році
у 2010 році якщо ви пам'ятаєте
українці На жаль обрали зека
у 2019 році
обрали зе
різниця між ними в одну букву І так же
стерлася
тому що
Янукович у десятому у 2013 році 10
грудня стався
день коли приїхала заступник Петра США
Вікторія Мулан
сьогодні
беркутня нова беркутня Зеленського
намагалася розігнати наш Майдан тут
прямо на очах у держсекретаря блінкіна а
Давайте скажемо
це місце великий за те що ви приїхали до
нас
самий відповідальний момент сюди
приїжджають
різні люди
ною
я сказав що є
[музика]
ми вимагаємо потягнути до
відповідальності всіх хто долучився до
сьогоднішнього покриття і ми точно
доб'ємося притягнення до
відповідальності
[музика]
В мене прохання А ви розібралися Хто
писав в дб
[музика]
н
щодо призначення мені безкоштовного
захисника перед зверталися не
розібралися не вдалося розбираємося
питання ми також
зацікавлені сьогодні
там на суд приїхав Штепа
[музика]
к його завершився
Я прошу пробачення в розібралися ви
зверталися по фізкультурному захисникам
звернулися чекаємо
ви звернулися за безкоштовним чи
звернутися за інформацією за інформацією
публікувати
черговий
сказав що є вільні повідомлення
[музика]
і саме тому Ми попереджали що це ворог і
саме тому ми говорили про те що наслідки
будуть жахлими якщо з 14 по 19-й рік під
керівництвом Порошенка армія з нуля
стала абсолютно боєздатною то за 2,5
роки в армії немає нормального
харчування немає забезпечення шоломами
дизель це я знайшов цю інформацію що
забезпечений лише на 17% мало того
зимовий дизель навіть не закупили то
куди б'є Зеленський Він б'є по збройним
силам України
яким не підвищували зарплату з 2019 року
якщо наші розвідники організовували
унікальні спецоперації при порошенкові
ТО при зеленському вони всі зриваються
на догоду ворогу Сьогодні ми пам'ятаємо
про справу вагнерівців
спецоперації зі звільнення українських
заручників з Донецької тюрми ізоляції А
також про інші речі які обов'язково
скоро стане відомо коли
[музика]
в 12-му році Росія намагалася знищити
Україну енергетично і знайшли можливість
забезпечити і вугіллям
Не російським вугіллям газом
амським вугіллям і європейським газом
український електростанції
то сьогодні
буваються вільні відключення
тут поставить за свій час
[музика]
повинні повторити цю помилку яка
коштувала потім мільйонів життів і за
часів голодомору і за часів сталінських
репресій лускувачування і за часів
переслідувань шістдесятників
всі ці люди заплатили своїм життям ту
ціну яка була виставлена за помилку
роз'єднання ми будемо єднатись
ми будемо стояти тут до перемоги
ми будемо робити все щоб захистити
Україну
ми будемо робити все щоб захистити від
політичного сиділилища лідера опозиції
Порошенка
тому я хочу сказати одне у свято
Водохреща Хай сьогодні всіх Бог
покропить святою водою а Святий Дух
надасть силу духу тому що він сьогодні в
Україні потрібен як нікому А якщо
Зеленський ховає свою родину на сейшелах
А сам ховається в буковелях з
коломойським на своїй резиденції то хай
він піде і не заважає українцям боронити
свою землю від ворога так
Слава Україні
Разом до перемоги
і ми переможемо обов'язково Слава
Україні
брати і сестри слово має голова
політичної партії голос Кіра Рудик
[музика]
Доброго дня друзі Слава Україні
я голова політичної партії голос ми
разом з європейською солідарністю
проукраїнська опозиція парламенту
коли я зустрів
яких таємних записів чи там фонограм чи
чогось від офісу Зеленського бо ми
опираємося виключно на те що і так
відомо що і так відкрито вся ця справа
підозра документи вони вже оприлюднені
кожен може їх прочитати кожен може і
подивитися Тому нам не треба
консервувати конспірологію потрібно
нашому опоненту вони наполягають що вона
там була Ми направляємо на тому що все
дуже-дуже очевидно і Закликаємо тільки
людей на власне очі подивитися що
відбувається і почитати хоча б документ
в нас це область
а наразі ми очікуємо коли повернеться
суддя ви знаєте що в нас несподівано
після під ті під тій годині
наради коли суддя перебував наразі в
понеділок коли ми зустрічалися навіть
нам було важко коли ми в чому були суді
а потім раптом оголошено що ухвала буде
сьогодні і ось ми на наш приносить як
юрист як може бути тільки один нема
підстав законних нема обґрунтованої
підозру не може бути затишному хвилі
»
.»
Я хотів би дорогі друзі подякувати
присутні отут
присутня тут Штефана фюлі людина яка
внесла зробила величезний внесок
підготовку і підписання угоди про
асоціацію включно з поглибленою та
всеохоплюючою зоною вільної торгівлі
людина яка теплодала зусиль по
звільнення політичних в'язнів часів
Януковича Тимошенко Луценко і дитина яка
не могла залишитися в остороні Сьогодні
вона разом з нами в залі суду для того
щоб боротися не тільки і не стільки за
Порошенка боротися за демократію
боротися за європейські вектор розвитку
і разом з заявами керівника
парламентського комітету асоціації
Європейського парламенту величезної
кількості світових лідерів
вчора ця тема була ключовою на всіх
світових заходів всіх світових засобах
масової інформації в мене запросили на
інтерв'ю
різноманітні канали починаючи від cонери
закінчуючи в Sky News починаючи від BBC
і тема була ключова на євроносі скрізь
позиція була наступна
пояснить що відбувається в Україні Чому
коли весь світ сьогодні докладає
максимум зусиль для того щоб зупинити
агресію і допомогти Україні українська
влада сама в собі замість того щоб
боротися з Путіним бореться з опозицією
наймаючи для цього абсолютно невдалих
виконавців роблячи абсолютно незрозумілі
сценарій і сьогодні в світі вже не
залишилося ні в кого сумніву щодо змісту
цього непотребу цієї макулатури які вони
принесли всю І тому сьогодні Хочу
наголосити що без цієї до цього моменту
прикутого увага всього світу Я дуже
дякую і українським і світовим засобам
масової інформації українськими світовим
медіа до того що ми на сьогоднішній день
не даємо перетворити в Україну малоросію
тому наша місія надзвичайно важлива
заказні справи переслідування опозиції
вибіркове правосуддя
знущання і наруга над верховенством
права побиття
мирної акції на якій присутні десятки
тисяч людей це є
картина проти якої Я боровся всі 5 років
своєї президентської каденції і буде
докладати максимум зусиль для того щоб
зараз об'єднати країну для вівці чи
Путіну А де для того щоб
дестабілізувати ситуацію всередині
країни для цього я повернувся Це моя
Місія це місія моєї команди і ми
переможемо Дякую Слава Україні
всі коментарі я не беру прогнозів і не
Гідрометцентр
[музика]
обіцяю що ви точно побачите
я вам обіцяю що ви точно побачите
[музика]
ура
ження
м Васильович
який вони сюди принесли нехай коментуйте
фальсифікацію
Скажіть будь ласка
визначається офіс президента Зеленського
йому сказали ні ні ні
ми будемо коментувати
будь ласка
українці
усміхнеться
доля
син наші воріже
ньки трах роса на
сонці
запануємо
браття у своїй
сторонці
гуси тіло при
положим за нашу свобо
Ду
покажем що ми браття
козацького роду
Душу тіло ми
положим за нашу свобо
покаже що ми браття козацького
роду
Слава Україні
Марина
росте руслане
Мустафа
проходьте 8
можна Я вибачаюсь Пропустіть будь ласка
і ви потім займати ці місця
до перемоги Ми багато залишили
щоб нічого
піднімають просто мікро
фон це чиєсь мікрофон бо він не працює
дорогі друзі я вас вітаю хоча Ніхто з
вас Ніхто з нас нічого
бо це свято всі з липомисли всі
Чортківські задуми вони приречені
і сьогодні нам це продемонстрували всіх
українців Я хочу привітати Христос
хрещається
і дуже добре що наша команда свій день
почала служби Божої в храмі
і після цього ми прийшли сюди
для того щоб продемонструвати що ми їх
не святкуємо перемогу хоча
Здавалося б ми перемогли
ми не святкуємо тому що божевільний
сценарій Зеленського як абсолютно
неадеквата ще не закінчиться
ми не святкуємо тому що сьогодні я ще
раз наголошую вчора в Києві 46 школ було
повідомлення про заміновані
і ми маємо діяти адекватної ефективно
ми не святкуємо тому що по всій країні
минуються псевдоминуються станції метро
вокзали підприємства
перешкоджаючи нормальному функціонуванню
України
ми не святкуємо тому що я твердо
наголошую що це є елементи гібридної
війни яке мають перед собою мету
залякати українців і знизити нашу
здатність
[музика]
Я Хочу наголосити як я діяв 14-му році
коли було набагато важно
[музика]
ви знаєте що політичні фракції які тоді
увійшли в коаліцію точно не були моїми
друзями і моїми партнерами Вони були
моїми опонентами
хоч Нехай Бог простить Самопоміч
випікальна партія блоків лілії Тимошенко
і всі але ми тоді сформували коаліцію і
більшість включить світло будь ласка
Відійдіть будь ласка
світло друзі і світло ще виключається в
будинку включить якщо можна
фонари відкрити штори
І от на сьогоднішній день ми маємо діяти
відповідально
діти тому що ми маємо рятувати Україну
як ми це зробили в 14
і перш за все Я хочу подякувати
своїй команді
яка
мала не дуже добре місяць
але була твердо переконана в перемозі
прав
навіть в такому правосудді тому що ніхто
наголошує ніхто не хоче ставати
радіоном киреевым які остаток життя буде
проводити в Росії
судді це розуміють
і дуже важливо щоб Зеленський розумів що
доля перетворення в Януковича і
проведення остатку життя в Ростові
це не Сейшельські острови
і всі мають зробити висновок і
незважаючи на ту несправедливість
незважаючи на ту на тебе пробування
незважаючи на те знущання через про який
проходить і ще буде проходити моя родина
Наша команда
ми Закликаємо
безвідповідально зелену владу
країна умови
поведінка агресора вимагає
загальнонаціонального консенсусу
ще раз наголошую Зеленський для мене
опонент ворог для мене Путін як і для
всієї нашої команди
ще раз наголошую Візьміть приклад
Великої Британії і великого прем'єра
уінстана черчилля який з перших днів
війни традиційно національної єдності
і це тривало аж до перемоги над
нацистською Німеччиною а після цього
знову почали внутрішні дискусії бо це
нормально
цивілізовані стосунки влади і опозиції і
це є абсолютно ненормально коли вся
правоохоронна система працює проти
лідеру опозиції і лідируючої опозиційної
політичної сили і це є абсолютно
ненормально коли
ми зранку
є ветеранів включно з Олександром
погребинським
ламає намети з яких просто роздавали чай
прибирають бочки просто роздавали чай
прибирають бочки в яких просто люди
грілися
Навколо яких
це дуже тривожні симптоми
друге я хочу подякувати журналістів
бо журналісти не зважаючи на
різне відношення до мене
ці дні
намагалися Андрію Вітаю Проходь дорогий
пане генерал Я радий що ви з нами
а дуже важливо що ви зайняли позицію
об'єктивності
нічого більше ми не потребуємо
я доводжу дякую також журналістів усього
світу бо вчора ця тема була провідною на
всіх телевізійних каналах світу
Але більш за все Я дякую простих
українців
які не зважаючи на свято незважаючи на
далеко відстані
приїхали сюди тисячі людей для того щоб
сказати рішуче ні
малоросізацію України
перетворення країни
малоросію часів Януковича Ні ми цього не
дозволимо зробити ми не дозволимо
знищити демократію ми не дозволимо
знищити економіку бо копілки вони
займаються Порошенком
друзі шість мільярдів гривень
іноземні інвестори вивели лише з початку
року з українських
зобов'язань це називається втеча
інвестицій спочатку року рік тільки
почався
6 мільярдів гривень більше півмільярда
доларів Національний банк вимушений був
розпродати
для того щоб підтримати курс
нічого не нагадує
пам'ятаєте Янукович плавав золотовалютні
резерви тому що нічого не міг
запропонувати для того щоби захистити
енергетику захистити економіку
Незважаючи на всі обіцянки Зеленського
підземних сховищах залишилися лише 12,5
мільярдів кубів газу з яких на
Нафтогаз може взяти лише 6
холодна зима
невідворотня приведе до катастрофи і ми
і наша команда знаємо як
захистити Україну знаємо що всім зробити
і ми не тягнемо ковдру для себе на себе
Ми кажемо скличте засідання Ради
національної безпеки і оборони
запросіть туди лідерів
опозиційних комітетів і лідерів партії
лідерів фракції
послухайте наші рекомендації бо від
нашої єдності залежить і доля країни і
доля людей
замість цього ми просто лякаєте людей
скличте позачергове засідання Верховної
Ради яку вимагає Наша команда ми
оприлюднили підпис
і слугам народа заборонили ставити
підписи під позачергове засідання де з
парламентом вищим законодавчим органом
держави ми обговоримо стратегію захисту
від Російської напади
а вони ще
продовжують соборством жовтня листопада
і грудня
спростовувати загрозу це неадекват і
божевілля
і саме тому
в мене не було іншого виходу
як повернутися
в перший день початку політичного сезону
саме тому
в мене не було іншого виходу
сподіваючись Що на цьому тижні мислимо
позачергове засідання парламенту
пояснить світу як
європарламент бундестаг Німеччини
Конгрес Сполучених Штатів Америки
Великої Британії
логова частина країн членів
Європейського Союзу НАТО
всі
стверджують що вони проводять окремо
засідання парламентів з українського
питання один парламент який не зібрався
це Верховна Рада України незважаючи до
вимогу всіх опозиційних прав
дорогі друзі Я хотів би відмітити
трохи вибивши з контексту роботу моїх
адвокатів
Ігоря голова
і її Новікова і всієї нашої команди Але
можу я попросити щоб після того як ви
насолодилися оплесками і повагою до вас
і присутні в залі глядачів щоб ви
підняли до судді взяли те що він зачитав
і хоч розповіли що там
я боюсь що може бути зарано святкувати
перемогу
Я сподіваюся що ми отримуємо це раніше
11 годин вечора
Дякую і всіх умов
Ми дякуємо простим українцям Ми дякуємо
волонтерам дякуємо ветеранам Ми дякуємо
активістам і Ми дякуємо нашим партнерам
політикам які ціни прості часи і Кіра
Рудики голос я дякую і Андрію кажемякіну
і батьківщині і представникам інших
політичних фракцій вони позавчора і
сьогодні є тут присутні
за те що вони розуміють що питання
національної державності питання
національної безпеки ми ставимо набагато
вище вузкопартійних або вузько
корпоративних інтересів це є поведінка
справжніх державників
і саме тому зараз ми спільно ми не
тягнемо ковдру на себе але ми спільно
Закликаємо до негайного об'єднання
демократичних опозиційних сил
для віці чи російській агресії
нічого важливіше бути не може
МС задоволенням згадуємо наше бойове
братерство в тому числі із генералами
14-го року коли ми спільно пліч боронили
державу тоді коли інші
бігали відповісток
грали на інструментах не руками
давали корпоративи в Горлівці окуповані
нехай
горять у них ці гроші які Вони
отримували за ці корпоративи
у нас час Дорогі друзі зараз
прихлопнути кришку піаніно
все
закінчився цей час і у нас зараз час
дати рішучі
ми до цього готові ми нікого не боїмося
ми рекомендації під час ефіру по
відношенню до переговорів з Путіним
складається з трьох частин перше
не вірте Путіну
щоб він не казав щоб він не обіцяв він
розуміє лише силу і нам треба стати
сильною державою а сильне може бути
тільки об'єднана друге не бійтесь Путіна
не тільки не шукайте нічого в його очах
Не бійтеся його
А ви навіть Кадирова
бойтеся і тричі вибачаєтесь перед ним
отже не бійтесь Путіна і третє
створить міжнародну коаліцію на
підтримку України Якщо ви хочете щоб
міжнародна коаліція була створена
покажіть що ви всередині створили
коаліцію для протидії російському
агресії Якщо ви хочете щоб весь світ
застосував санкції проти Росії проти
Білорусі територія яких може бути
використана для агресії проти нас перші
Перестаньте купувати білоруську
електроенергію
Перестаньте купувати продукцію України
агресора
Тоді у вас з'явиться нині економічні
питання
вас з'явиться моральне право звертатися
до партнерів по коаліції зробити те саме
Це коли мене питають що нам потрібно від
наших партнерів перше сам
і це не питання економічні санкції
послаблюють країну агресії а нам треба
щоб вони були послаблені
друге
збільшить
обороноздатність
України
і це є постачання сучасної оборонної
смертельної зброї
і це є
зупинка північного потоку-2
реформа сектору безпеки і це є спільні
навчання і передачі технологій і це є
передача розвід даних і це є головне
план дій щодо членства в НАТО тому що це
буде демонстрація світові
що ми не піддалися на його альтиматум А
чому бо ми його не боїмося і ми йому не
віримо
а гарантії Путіна ви можете перевірити
на прикладі Будапештського меморанду
який свого часу був підписаний
лідерами України
А на сьогоднішній день виявляється
папірцем не вартий папір на якому він
був надрукований Отже ніякі гарантії від
Путіна не працюють працюють в світі лише
один договор
вашингтонський і 5 стаття Про що цей
договір про створення
Північноатлантичного Союзу
і нам не існує інших варіантів як
відкриті двері і я пишаюся тим що за 5
років мого президентства кількість людей
українців які підтримали вступ України
до НАТО збільшилися з 16 до 60%. ви не
можете йти проти волі народу і тому ми
разом з нашими партнерами ввели
обов'язкові зовнішньої політики України
як Транс атлантична і європейська
інтеграція
для мене це позиція є принципом
і ще одна річ на яку хотів би звернути
вашу увагу
зараз офіс президента нагадує
божевільний доступ
зараз
вони не знають що і як їм робити їх
сценарій
який так ретельно готувався провокації
не пройшов випробувань
навіть в Печерському суду
І що ще може бути доказом І
підтвердженням
абсолютно злочинної місії прокурорів як
виконавців
абсолютно злочинної місії слідчих дбр
абсолютно злочинної брехливої компанії
політичної сили які нас в цьому
звинувачували
І абсолютно твердої позиції
Великого українського батька Кобзаря
який свого часу сказав
боритися
і
оремо і нехай нам всім українцям Бог
помагає
я би я переповнений зараз емоціями но
якісь папір отримали адвокат
ви можете ви сюди прийти бо
зніми маску і голос не читає як ти
прокурором але
відносно Порошенка Петра Олексійовича
процесуальні обов'язки прибувати за
кожного вимогою до органу досудового
розслідування прокурора російського суду
а в разі неможливості
з'явиться поважні причини завчасно
повідомляти про це посадову особу орган
сьогоднішним виклик не відлучатися із
міста Києва та Київської області без
дозволу слідчого прокурора або суду
повідомляти скільки про про зміни до
місця свого проживання та аби роботи
здати на зберігання до відповідних
органів державної влади в свій паспорт
паспорти
здати на зберігання до відповідних
органів державної влади свій паспорт
паспорти для виїзду за кордон інші
документи що дають право на виїзд з
України і В'їзд в Україну
і це абсолютно незаконно
бути заходів для продовження
м
дії ухвалення за 19 березня
Я Хочу наголосити ви знаєте відповідь на
це питання щоб безумовно що це обмеження
з урахуванням того що я зараз маю
запрошення до як мінімум трьох
закордонних візитів перший з яких
починається вже 25 числа
вилучення паспорту перешкоджає моїй
політичній діяльності
виїзд за межі Києва обмеження
перешкоджає моєї внутрішньополітичній
діяльності і це саме те чого боїться
Зеленський і це саме те за що він і його
комарілі татарове смирнови всі ці
негідники які намагалися це забезпечити
будуть за це відповідати мова бути
відповіді дальності не тільки у вигляді
епіляції Я ще раз наголошую що політичне
переслідування лідери в опозиції Ми
сподіваємося
найде відповідно реакцію Із точки зору
наших міжнародних партнерів
ми будемо принаймні звертатися і просити
про це
друзі
ні Бо у нас судді Незалежності
але
свою долю
міцних слів українська влада від наших
американських партнерів
перше нічого
друге мене обмежили вони і не
сподівалися на арешт вони намагалися
перешкодити моїй політичній діяльності
раз і вони намагалися дискредувати
дискредитувати мене в очах виборців 2 і
вони намагалися дискредитувати мене в
очах світу 3
дискредитація в очах виборців ніхто їм
не повірив
[музика]
дискредитація в очах світу точно
зворотній ефект
обмеження політичної діяльності єдине що
в них находилися в їх руках бо вони нас
бояться але їм це не допоможе я
наголошую на тому що свою політичну
діяльність я буду активно проводити
включно
з участю
міжнародних закладах який заздалегідь
заплановано коли ми вдячні люди чекають
Спасибі друзі
[музика]
[сміх]
порох є да
мо брати і сестри
поки ми чекаємо на вихід Петра
Олексійовича Я хочу на коротко запросити
до слова Марусю звіробій
Слава нації
смерть ворогам - це головне що мають
знати про українців в той момент коли
кійок правоохоронця піднімається на
мирних демонстрантів в той момент коли в
кримінальних справах відсутні докази
причетності до злочинів в той момент вже
не йдеться про прізвища в той момент
ідеться про демократію сьогодні прийшли
не лише люди які за Порошенка сьогодні
прийшли люди які хочуть бачити якщо ви
судите надайте докази якщо у вас немає
доказів що це за цирк і я надзвичайно
Дякую кожному хто прийшов сьогодні тому
що це питання для українця принципове
Зеленський має зрозуміти що українці
вийдуть за кого захочуть вчора тебе
дурня підтримали сьогодні захочуть
Порошенка підтримують і не треба думати
що ти вдів корону до корони в українців
взагалі досить агресивне ставлення і
сьогодні коли влетіло жіночками тут які
принесли бу терброди демонстрантам
то робиться за чим
курвидні понимаю в цій державі друзі
Дякую вам дякую
правоохоронцям яким там соромно стояти а
такі є і коли кажуть що правоохоронці
забулися 2014 рік Ні не забулися але їх
багато нових і моє велике прохання вже є
атовці з усіх боків є у правоохоронній
системі брати з якими ми воювали будь
ласка Майте свідомість хоча б цікавтесь
той легендою Яку вам надають коли
розказують про яких з диких
демонстрантів тут і Якщо ви будете
порушувати закон да українці бувають
дикі ну його в баню оце бачите одні вже
подивилися летіли всі в деяких
похоронили
їх похоронили Дякую друзі Вам слава
Україні
[оплески]
знаєте друзі Мені одна ситуація ранкова
з нашими чорноформениками Мені дуже
нагадувало Ведмедя і
диких бджіл коли Медвідь лізе забирати
мед а дикі бджоли лісові починають
захищати своє
ми з вами є отими бджолами Ми живемо у
своєму вулику і ми нікому не дозволимо
наказам іменами наказами зі своїми
баченнями
і
коаліції хто працює там від 13-14 року
Розкажіть будь ласка новачкам отим
запальним що буває
зустрічаємо
тиша Порошенко
[оплески]
будь ласка дай сюди
горошинку
Слава Ісусу Христу
сьогодні Господь точно був на цій площі
Сьогодні
ми продемонстрували як багато залишить
від кожного з вас
не було б цього Україна була би її
були
байдужі Україна була би інша
були по інші
і головне моє мої слова подяки вам
дорогі українці
ті хто сьогодні в Києві і по всіх
куточках України
Хто вийшов на протест велика дякую
хто не давав поліції знищити мітинг
Велике дякую хто молився в церкві і це
теж дуже важливо
і вам здається що сьогодні вже є повна
перемога тому що Зеленський
отримав клуб
в своїх
бажаннях таємних
заарештувати Порошенка і призначити 1
млрд заставу
не працює бо це Україна
це не малоросія Януковича і тим більше
не Росія
Але чи є це повною перемогою Ні це лише
перший крок в правильному напрямку
це рішення демонструє страхи Зеленського
це рішення демонструє чого він боїться
а боїться він
щоби Порошенко
не проводив політичної роботи і тому
йому заборонили порошенкові
покидати Київ і Київську область
Чи згодимося ми з цим
чекайте нашої відповіді
друга
він наполягав і уклінно просив
щоб у Порошенка забрали закордонні
паспорти
щоб Порошенка не міг виїжджати за кордон
зустрічатися з друзями і партнерами
України
божевілля неадекват
бо на сьогоднішній день ми маємо
використовувати всі можливості для того
щоб збудувати коаліцію світову на
підтримку України перед нападом Путіна
він вилучає паспорти
тоді коли 24
січня в мене була перша поїздка до НАТО
чи є запрошення участі в міжнародних
формах цього вони бояться Чи змиримося
ми з цим
нехай чує
третє поїздка він був третя пункт
порядку денного він думає що всі
протести це лише тому що їх фінансує
Порошенко
і тому єдине з його точки зору кроків
для того щоб припинити
зупинку його божевільних дій
[музика]
- це заарештувати все майно і всі
рахунки Порошенка вони це зробили Чи
змиримося ми з цим
не зважаючи на те що ніхто з тисяч людей
які прийшли сюди жоден ми прийшов за
гроші
А за Зеленського
без грошей Ви нікого не виведете цім ми
відрізняємося від них так чи ні
чуйте це і тому
це лише перші кроки нашої боротьби але я
вас вітаю тому що сьогоднішній бій не
війну
не стратегію але сьогоднішній бій ми з
вами виграли це наша з вами перемога і з
нами
з нами правда із нами Бог і ви велике
молодці І разом до нашої спільної
Перемоги ви
хотіли пороха
[музика]
ви його маєте зараз коли є порох
дамо вогню
дякую
круто
дякую дякую друзі
ви великі молодці я вас дуже люблю Ми
разом найкраща команда в Україні але
сьогодні сьогодні наше з вами місія і
завдання об'єднати всі демократичні сили
продемонструвати Єдність і проти вас
тривати що ці Ми Точно відрізняємося від
недолуги не компетентний не української
зеленої влади Слава Україні
[оплески]
і у нас є добра традиція до якої ми
маємо повернутися Софія Федина каже що я
не дуже добре співаю але гімн ми з вами
співаємо найкраще
[музика]
[оплески]
ще ні
слава ні во
обще
[музика]
ці
усміхнеться
доля
Згинуть наші
воріженьки як роса на
сонце
забанує мій ми браття у
своїй
сторонці
Душу й тіло ми
положим за нашу свобо
Ду
і покажем що ми
браття
козацького ро
[музика]
Ду
що й тіло ми
[музика]
положим за
нашу свобо
Ду
[музика]
що ми
браття козацького
[музика]
[оплески]
друзі разом та Перемоги
товариство брати і сестри ми зберігаємо
спокій ми зберігаємо спокій без тисняви
всі встигнуть без тисняви будь ласка Ми
зараз формуємо колону голова колони
буде пскої площі тобто від вас це по
праву руку
в міру
з від себе Ми пересуваємось до машини
озвучки і ми будемо рухатись на банкову
чашує про те що
між при виявлені таких по можливості
затримуйте Передавайте продам по зброї
якщо не маєте можливості затримати
фіксуйте ці порушення на відео і
пам'ятайте що ми нікого не боїмося ми
нічого не боїмося з нами правда З нами
бог
Вся Україна Слава Україні
Слава нації
Україна
[музика]
Путін Земля
Володя ми до тебе йдем годуйся
Вітаю вас друзі нині ми знаходимо
вітаємо друзі нині ми знаходимося ще
поряд з печерським судом тут зібралася
дуже багато людей мені навіть складно
вам сказати яка тут може буде їх
кількість
[музика]
нараду офісу президента переді мною
стоїть політичним репресіям перепрошую
не дочитала
за дуже короткий час ця колона рушить
нагадаю
саме в понеділок 17 січня Петро
Олексійович Порошенко прилетів до
України у його
було кохання мало би бути
господарському суді
до нашої пізнавальної екскурсії центру
Києва
правда висловити свою думку свою
похід Петро Петро олексійовичу
питання але арешт із майна
чи декілька хвилин Я так бачу ми
розуміємо і вже буде рухатися колона тут
справді дуже багато людей дуже багато
журналістів все Ми потихеньку
Скажіть будь ласка з банером
[музика]
просто зараз знаходиться
Який теж
[музика]
можна це вважати якусь перемогою
ви знаєте я хочу відповісти на це
питання це мала але тактична перемога
перемога над тим правосуддям заказним
яке на сьогоднішній день ми бачимо в
нашій державі політично заказне
правосуддя на сьогоднішній день
відбулося те що повинно було відбутися
перш за все той запобіжний захід який
винесли в залі суду ми розуміємо що
знову ж таки є певні обмеження є певні
обмеження лідера опозиції що всі ці
питання цілком сфабриковані
доказів не було але я не знаю чому суддя
був вимушений прийняти таке рішення Я
думаю що перемога попереду Чому тому що
всі ці питання прописані нам Конституції
прописані нашим законодавством
м перш за все будемо боротися далі
розкажіть це можна якось порівняти з тим
процесом який відбувався Влад вам це так
само тут все триває тобто вони не
зрозумілі докази
Ви знаєте це перш за все Я хочу сказати
що це замовні справи який на
сьогоднішній день на жаль мають місце
саме приклади
[музика]
України які є на сьогоднішній день не
обґрунтовані
Я не розумію чому на сьогоднішній день в
нашій державі не дають дійсно нормальної
гарантії правосуддя які нам визначені
конституцією Як ви думаєте чим все це
завершиться Чи можемо ми сподіватися на
перевагу я знаю що це завершиться
перемогою і ніякі інакше тому що
справедливість на боку на боці людей
добре Дякуємо вам отже поспілкувалися з
генералом козловським а далі Я пропоную
вам показати що тут
власне
що тут власне саме засідання завершилось
[музика]
чимось люди пішли
дощу А ось тече
[музика]
запобіжний захід у Вірі Віра і особисто
зобов'язання і також арештували майном
5-го президента
[музика]
А ось поки можемо бачити що відбувається
ось Собака вона пішла вже тихо
спокій
[музика]
но ну і зараз також ми подивимося одразу
тут є зараз попробувати якимось з
активістів А скажіть будь ласка
розцінюйте рішення яке сьогодні
[музика]
відбулося
все ж таки активіста допомагалися
але
[музика]
різко далі Можливо ви зараз підете на
банку Ну що будете допомагати
на банкову
треба вимагати повернення паспортів
[музика]
Як вас звати
все ж таки
[музика]
перед особистого зобов'язання
не сподівався на те що це буде
Отже ми зараз продовжимо слідкувати за
подіями і будемо
можливості
[музика]
І передавати їх працівникам поліції
на за громадське затримання немає
на телефони робимо відеозйомку цих
порушень
передається свого роду
[музика]
не
[оплески]
[музика]
зламні велику суть для усіх єдино в наш
горний Клич народові несе
Вечірній Луцьк
[музика]
[оплески]
мене
на руки героєм наших Слава для нас
законом найвищий козакам
українська є держа
ва на
вікно поправках
[музика]
вона від
можливості працювати і закрити за якою
статтею за державну зраду
[музика]
сформована міжнародна коаліція підтримки
України це перемога
але
просто державна зрада
ринок
ті товари які ми продаємо були машини
був переорганізований з Росії на Європу
це перемога так для Зеленського Це зрада
Володя ви тут на бензин Володя Ми на
тебе йде Володя ми до тебе йде Володя ми
до тебе йдем
[оплески]
що зараз на банковій відбуваються
черговий етап паніки страшної паніки він
боїться він боїться Голосу народу він
боїться Голосу України
він чує тільки себе і іншого голосу він
не сприймає але ми Українці Ми готові
йому сказати свою думку ми готові
відстоювати своє і ми не так сьогодні
боремося за пороха ми боремося за
цемографію ми боремося за демократичну
Україну Ми хочемо щоб Україна була
цивілізованою країною хто є наше право
як у громадян цієї країни багато з нас
це право захищали на сході в чате
російсько-української війни
тільки СССР проливу свою кров і
залишились на вічного поля в Донбасу і
то є ціна вільної України
хто його що Зеленський зараз
є політичних хамство і підприєв ми не
дамо перетворити Україну на Росію
Україна не Росія
Україна не Росія Україна не Росія
[музика]
і брати і сестри Я хочу вам сказати хай
не буде у вас страху Хай вас налякають
що мовляв ми тут піднімаємо нове
повстання ми вже маємо на це право як
так Україна ослаблена Так це говорить
Зеленський це говорить його життя
говорить його шістьорки я вам скажу що
ми маємо право на громадський протест
право висловити свою думку
маємо право сказати своє слово
[музика]
виборюємо кожного дня на східних фронтах
Ми не Росія Ми на Білорусія ми на
Казахстан ми з вами є великою
весною Україною Слава Україні
[оплески]
[музика]
[сміх]
брати і сестри
ви пам'ятаєте цей Майдан ви знаєте його
як свої п'ять пальців Ви знаєте цю площу
ви пам'ятаєте цю бруківку
це єднання яке було в 14-му році в 13-му
14-му роках коли на одній переказі були
сусідняки і Захисники і українці з
півночі і славетний Крим нашу
український режим всі були тут
і ми зараз брати і сестри будемо йти по
Святому місту
після лякає те що ми своїми ногами
Будемо іти по вулиці Героїв Небесної
Сотні То є наша святиня то є наше право
тут ходити
ми згадуємо наших братів і СССР які
відійшли до Господа як вони тест на
Сотня і вони будуть жити до тих пір поки
ми про них пам'ятатимемо
Майдан живий Майдан живий Майдан живий
Майдан живий
[музика]
герой не вмирають Герої не вмирають
вмирають вороги
[музика]
героїв української землі
слава слава
слава рогам
укаті тричі смерть
[музика]
смерть
свободу будемо захищати будь-якою ціною
[музика]
ми знаємо що таке втрачене життя
але ми цього не боїмося ми знаємо що це
плата за добре життя наших дітей наших
внуків
[музика]
ви подивіться позаду як нас багато
Це є Україна це є всі
пісні
разом сила разом
разом сила
[музика]
[оплески]
знову Свободи ми знаємо ціну волі
ми на цих вулицях на цій вулиці на цій
алеї текла кров героїв
червона кров наших героїв
[музика]
тому були першими новітніми героями
України наша Небесна сотня яку ми мусимо
пам'ятати дивіться ми вшанувати і не
тільки згадувати всі пам'яті
в лютому чи згадувати на день початку
Революції гідності
[музика]
як нагадування що ми не маємо права на
помилку
Ми не маємо права вступити крок назад
ціна яку зараз яка заплачена є
надзвичайно високою
наші брати і сестри
зараз дивляться на нас і Я переконаний
що вони горді вони гордість Що Ми
продовжуємо їхню справу
чи хтось з них хотів помирати
чи з'їхав до Києва щоб отримати кулю
вони їхали ще боротися вони їхали
виборювати своє право жити вільний в
державі і це право вони
[музика]
мали прийшов маленький зелений виродок
який починає говорити що ми п'єте
договоримся посередині
з ким ти збираєшся домовлятися падлюка
зелена
або з ки
[музика]
м ти тому що ти не маєш ні сили ні волі
ні характеру так Володя я звертаюся тебе
[музика]
загиблих
учасників російсько-української війни
визвольної
війни каже триває сотні років
[музика]
і нам тут жити і нашим дітям тут жити
Герої не вмирають Герої не вмирають
Герої не вмирають
умирають Герої не вмирають Герої не
вмирають
Героям Небесної Сотні тричі
тут завжди і повсякчас пам'ятаємо про
подвиг звичайних простих українців
який не получив смерті
хочуть
улучити що півкулі вони йшли під кулі
вони йшли рятувати своїх побратимів
і тодішні працівники так званих
правоохоронних органів
вони також виконували наказ
ви пам'ятаєте вони також виконували
наказ
[музика]
Все я так кажу просто на майбутнє хлопці
в формі дівчата в формі Я вірю що багато
з вас саме працівників поліції прийшли
на цю роботу з найщарішими почуттями я
вірю Це я знаю порядних серед вас
Будьмо людьми
Будьмо людьми тому що саме це робить нас
українцями ми вміємо переживати ми
вміємо підтримувати один одного
брати і сестри
нагадую всім що ми йдемо на банкову
усім незадоволеним які по боках всякі
там я забув як їх називають берети
[музика]
старшого віку люди яким не подобається
наша хода я вам кажу згиньте і не
заважайте будувати Україну
товариство Я хочу вам наголосити що на
території
офісу президента знаходиться тимчасові
споруди різноманітні намети ми їх не
чіпаємо
[музика]
я наголошую намети різноманітні
тимчасові споруди які знаходяться на
території офісу президента ми їх не
чіпаємо ми не прийшли нищити ми не
прийшли ламати ми прийшли запитати ми не
прийшли захоплювати поки що
пішли запитати чому відбувається Саме
так а не інакше чому я наголошую про
намети які стоять на території офісу
президента Я вже вам говорив що між нами
є провокатори яким можуть сіли
спрямовано
дискредитувати Нашу З вами мирну акцію
тому черговий раз Оголошую що ми прийшли
не ламати не мігшити не захоплювати
саміткою поки що питання зірочкою ми з
вами цивілізовані люди Ми є українцями
вони совістю цієї нації
непасіонарії які готові рухати Україну
до позитивних змін
разом сила разом сила разом сила
мене
а наша
[музика]
родини
хулігани старі його матері
[музика]
сестри
залишаємось на місці доходимо будь ласка
підтягуйте сюди поки наші працюють
звукова обладнання на банкові будь ласка
зачекайте поки тут
Зачекайте тут для тих для товариства
шановного Яке зараз підходить для вкотре
нагадую і наголошую що ми прийшли не
ламати не нищити і не захоплювати поки
що
[музика]
на території офісу президента точніше не
до президента знаходиться багато
тимчасових
вих багатонаметів дитяча атракціони ми
їх не зачіпаємо
від слова взагалі
між нами є провокатори які свідомо і
цілеспрямовано можуть нищити те майно ми
цього не робимо
[музика]
звертають до вас
як мені здається
[музика]
А ми шановні
колеги прийшли
здати
з якого
віку - Україна
[музика]
!
косметичку
свою забрати Що ми робимо кажи бігом
підтримати і говорити
раз два три чотири п'ять
соловейкоди-куди Андрій
[музика]
су
Дини
[музика]
чекайте чекайте чекайте будь ласка
ми зараз приїхали до офісу президента
саме на вулицю банкову ось ми бачимо Ми
приїхали разом з колоною там за парканом
знаходиться величезна кількість людей
Вони всі потрохи починають сюди
підходити збиратися то звичайно є і
правоохоронні органи які під час того як
ми їхали разом з колоною вони
продовжували вони спостерігали за самим
порядком що все було безпечно тут
потроху ми бачимо що вже підходять люди
зустрічаємось на їх знайомих давайте
подивимось поспілкуємося Можливо ми
когось зустрінемо запитаємо
що сьогодні тут відбувається що нам
Скажуть люди з якими на настроєм
сьогодні сюди прийшли Давайте ми трішки
з оператором пройдемо вперед там ще
побачити показати вам точніше саму
колону величезну кількість людей я так
розумію вони наразі згуртовуються аби
зайти сюди саме до офісу президента їх
насправді дуже багато величезна
кількість я не можу навіть сказати вам
саме скільки ось ви можете вже побачити
є прапори є музика
кричать вони гасла різні
дуже до них наближаємося як ви бачите
ось
[музика]
буде який сьогодні сюди прийшли давайте
поспілкуємося от я бачу сьогодні тут вже
є Де подати знайомі
Добрий день вам давайте з вами
поспілкуємося Які у вас сьогодні настрій
Я хотів би вам сказати що тільки що
сталося а тільки що сталося тоді ви
пам'ятаєте як
пан Путін казав що вони виставлять
посеред перед своїми військами жінок і
дітей після того підуть от зараз на
банковій Зеленський прикрився дітьми і
жінками
от туди зараз нагнали жінок дітей для
того щоб захиститися від українця ви
розумієте що коїться
[музика]
Ну ми про свою власну безпеку і
прикривається дітьми не своїми
[музика]
ми бачимо далі які
Ми бачили
були способи використання поліції зранку
були подібні речі але бачимо
найголовніше коли люди об'єднані і не
страшні прокурори слідчі дбр
навіть добре вистачило мудрості відкрити
закон прочитати його і зробити Я думаю
що Максимум з того що він міг ближче до
цього закону очевидно що депутат що
[музика]
там нелогічні положення про позбавлення
Петра Порошенка можливості вести
внутрішній зовнішній поїздки і подібне
очевидно що з цим маразмом будемо
боротися але зараз
[музика]
ви впровадить за прокає можливості цьому
перешкоду дякую нічого не Ростислава Ми
продовжуємо далі спостерігати Зараз ми
трішечки підійдемо показати люди
дозволять давайте пропустимо машину
ми трішки вам ще покажемо людей трішки
відійдемо від звуку щоб ви і могли
почути і коли ми будемо спілкуватися з
людьми
ми зараз зустріли
разом
[музика]
сьогодні переможний не насправді тут
історії Перемоги не тільки там Петро
Порошенко перемогу українців людей які
воліють бути вільними які б не будуть
вказувати де стояти що робити Ви бачили
що сьогодні правоохоронні
вони крали у людей діжки вони не дали
людям випити чаю і це насправді показує
їх варварство але люди все одно йшли
йшли ви бачите за моєю спиною просто
шалена кількість людей і це значить що
люди хочуть жити в демократичність
вільній країні то можливо прийти і
висловити своє слово тут всі кричать
целю геть тому що в країні незалежній
Україні немає місця диктаторам і
тоталітарним режимом Януковича і
Зеленського так само тому сьогоднішній
день це день в історії
[музика]
сільського режиму який Зеленський
намагався нам вдома
навіть в нього це не вийшло тому що за
нашими спинами сотні тисяч людей настрій
кожної Я сподіваюсь що нас все ж таки
Зеленський почує і припинив усі
політичні переслідування тому що тут
справа настільки Порошенко це справа є
справа по грибицького і справа е-е
ветеранів волонтерів і усіх тих хто на
сьогоднішній день страждає від цього
режиму Я сподіваюсь що все ж таки судова
і правоохоронна система буде на стороні
людей а не на стороні телефонного права
Зеленського бачите люди кричать думок Я
сподіваюсь що сьогоднішній день все ж
таки залишиться пам'ять багато побиття
активістів Що ви можете сказати загалом
дивіться на
сьогоднішній день
на зв'язок ведемо
яку ми виходимо на мір мирні акції за
для того щоб захистити своє право тому
що якщо посадять Дорошенко то посадять і
всіх наступних і це вже знаєте така
репресивна машина яку не можна зупинити
вони знаєте увійдуть у смак тому звісно
люди які просто захищали навіть
документи їх зносили намети порвали
діжки вкрали і мені здається що вони
просто не розуміють що Воля людей
[музика]
цінність яка народилася на Майдані
цінності
європейського вектору розвитку країни
ціль свободи слова були виявлення тому
мені здається що на сьогоднішній день
правоохоронна система просто взяла і
знищила своє обличчя але я хочу
подякувати всім
правоохоронцям прокурорам суддям хто не
лягає під
утиски Зеленського Хто все ж таки стоїть
і розуміє що закон і народ це основа
держави демократичної держави і не можна
знаєте все це перекреслювати і
виконувати вказівки банкове тому я
сподіваюсь що все ж таки наша країна
буде розвиватися в демократичному
напрямку величезне вам дякую Дякуємо
наші телеглядачам нагадуємо що ми зараз
знаходимося поряд офісом президента
Будемо продовжувати спілкуватися з
людьми яких ми будемо тут зараз
зустрічати нагадаю сьогодні Чому сюди
вирішили люди підійти сьогодні був суд
стосовно справи Петра Порошенка і все ж
таки він закінчився добре від
правлялася справді дуже багато людей і
вони вирішили так як би мовити як вони
самі повідомили просто передати привіз
зеленському і прийшли під офіс
президента ми будемо продовжувати
рухатися далі шукати звукового ми можемо
що запитати Можливо ми Когось зараз
знайдемо он ось бачу Анна Володимира
в'ятровича Дозвольте будь ласка
Добрий день вам ще раз які в настрої в
настрій сьогодні маєте зараз бадьорий
переможний ми виграли важливу Битву
очевидно що війна попереду в першу чергу
війна з Путіним ми назбираємся воювати
Зеленського ми тут власне для того щоб
Зеленський не допомагав Путіну
ослаблювати Україну і сьогодні на цьому
шляху ми зробили важливі
кроки І буду перемога надзвучкою Скажіть
будь ласка як ви взагалі відноситись до
цієї ситуації з побиттям активістів
зранку дуже дивно якось агресивно
поводилася поліція треба було її
заспокоювати Слава Богу це вдалося
першим приводом стало взагалі якісь
дивні речі спроба вкрасти три бочки які
через кілька хвилин після цього
повернули потім е-е чомусь накинувся на
нашу побратима політв'язнів Володимира
балоха якого не цікаво Артемом чи будем
теж тому що ми були визволяє
загалом Слава Богу ситуація нібито
заспокоїлась і ми зараз будемо дивує що
на подвір'ї офісу президента так багато
людей і мотивують хто по два продаж там
з'явилися ті діти Звичайно що ми не
підемо туди тому що ми тут справді
заради зокрема і тих дітей Скажіть будь
ласка
звільнили Слава Богу нічого не стало за
правоохоронці до автомобіля поставилися
зрозуміли що зробили трошки неправильно
і на цьому інцидент вичерпано
і скажи рішення сьогоднішнього який суд
все-таки ухвалив так стосовно Чи це було
очікувано чи не очікувано
Звичайно що не очікувано і
товариші аби не було якби не було
скільки людей на вулицях насправді е
рішення є перемогою проміжною перемогою
неоднозначно тому
що хто заарештувати Порошенка
з другого боку обмежити його пересування
за кордоном жодним неприпустимо до
задачі на те як Україна зараз потребує
будь-якої дипломатичної підтримки а-а
крім цього іншого Порошенка - це
величезний дипломатичний капітал який
працює і має працювати на Україну
[музика]
Дякую відповідь давайте ще з вами
поспілкуємося
ваш настрій діліться враженнями сьогодні
все ж таки що сьогоднішній день для вас
значують
повернемося на вісім років назад Це
майдан 14-й рік Водохреща
палає Майдан і вже його тоді охрестили
Вогник
Ми хочемо ще поспілкуватися з деякими
людьми нагадаю що Який по завершенню
суду люди всі вирішили піти до офісу
президента аби самому зеленському
передати вітання Зараз ми будемо
трішечки рухатись і шукати всім ще можна
поспілкуватися я бачу сьогодні тут дуже
багато молоді що досить такі приємно що
вони приїхали саме підтримати
з Києва так Дозвольте що будь ласка з
вами поспілкуватися добре іде
ї Які у вас настрій діліться враженнями
дуже гарний ну по-перше святковий в
будь-якому разі святковий бо сьогодні у
нас День коли ми ось уже маємо весну і
весно не тільки в природі а весною
вважаю політиків в боротьбі в усьому і
Ми змінимо на краще світ Ми змінимо на
краще
Україну і Я впевнений всі люди ті що
сьогодні тут і ті що в Україні
зможуть ми вистояли вистояємо і
переможемо а Путін пішов
той путь країни все буде гарно і все
буде добре
[музика]
Чому ви зараз сюди прийшли чому пройшли
Ми пройшли сказати
[музика]
зрозуміло можливо якісь подальші плани
дії щось має не бо я розуміюся що все ж
таки не фінал І що плануєте далі робити
не фінал Ми продовжуємо робити те що ми
почали робити захищаємо Україну
захищаємо на всіх фронтах Це мається на
увазі так як наші побратими по сестрі на
фронті Так ми захищаємо то не даємо
зломити Україну не даємо прийняти закони
які ламають Україну не даємо зруйнувати
Україну зсередини і не даємо
додаємо що відбулась
Це наші плани
Спасибі вам за вашу позицію давайте ще
Добридень і вам поспілкуємося з вами ваш
настрій діліться дуже бойовий Я хочу
сьогодні подякувати нашим українцям Я їх
дуже люблю навіть тих які сьогодні не з
нами бо тому що в певний час вони мені
могли зрозуміти хто Я є і зробити свій
вибір
тому українці я вас люблю сюда його
прекрасний ми сьогодні ми сьогодні
тільки проміжна перемога
але
років нас закалка є в нас витримання все
буде добре на вашу думку чи сьогоднішнє
рішення суду було особисто для вас
очікуваним воно для мене воно скоріш
було вони вибрали таке середнє вони не
хотіли да да ганьба ганьба вони не
хотіли
категоричний завоялися присудити там
Олексійовича чи закритий чи би там
[музика]
таке середнє е-е але це рішення якраз
було завдяки тому що люди прийшли вони
якби якби не прийшлось скільки людей
а сьогодні то Ну не знати Якби було але
от дякуючи людям що прийшли підтримали
нас прийшли підтримали Петра
Олексійовича за цей рівень Дякую вам
велике нага
дуємо нашим телеглядачам що ми
це попри президентом ми були ми
Стараємося ще трішки пройти далі ми
будемо спілкуватися
[музика]
сьогодні ще є люди давайте Добрий день з
вами поспілкуємося Які у вас сьогодні
настрій і чому ви прийшли президента
[музика]
тому що він буде тут тема гірше для
нього буде тому що покарання його нас
дожене ти
Ні мене чекають ні в Москві
за кордоном він був
[музика]
братами і буде
реально
і хочу зараз передати слово по своїй
колезі Вікторії Максима Вікторія тобі
слово
Дякую Юля за передачу слова а я ж покажу
яка ситуація нині у нас от ми бачимо
офіс президента його всього заставили ми
бачимо такими яскравими всілякими
будиночками різдвяними однак в тій
стороні величезний мітинг там проходять
поступово люди Ми бачимо що частину
людей вже пропустили але більша частина
людей залишається ще там і як ми
розуміємо вони проходять через кордон
поліції через металошукачі і сьогодні
люди Після рішення Печерського районного
суду міста Києва пройшли сюди під офіс
президента власне
сказати свою позицію і зараз ми
поспілкуємося з людьми в прямому ефірі
Добрий день ви в прямому ефірі Скажіть
будь ласка чому сьогодні прийшли на
банкову після Печерського суду я була
19-го числа ми приїхали з Харкова і
приїхали сьогодні підтримати нашого
Гетьмана тому що ми не згодні щоб
відбувається в нашій країні ми не згодні
з тим що нашого лідера опозиції
постійно якісь підозри шити білими
нитками це всі
мисліші люди все це розуміють і нас це
все обурює тому що завтра
може знати кожному з нас можуть прийти і
пред'являти нам такі справи Ну такі що в
чому ми відстоїмо свою незалежність ми
свободні громадяни і ми знаємо що
Свобода правда з нами і з нами Бог тому
ми сьогодні тут і скільки надо буде
скільки що буде від нас залежити ми
будемо робити скажіть будь ласка
особисто вас обурило рішення Печерського
районного суду з приводу того що
наприклад Петро Порошенко не зможе
відвідати НАТО куди його запрошували
конечно обурює тому що він залишається
лідером України і його Ну до нього
прислухаються його чують спільнота
всесвітня і тому конечно обурює це те що
в нього забрали паспорт то що він не
зможе
підтримувати нашу країну в світі
Дякуємо вам дуже поспілкувалися з людьми
наживо і кажуть про те що обурює те що
п'яте президент України Петро Порошенко
не зможе потрапити до НАТО і
[музика]
не з позиції А зараз Як ми знаємо на
кордонах дуже така неспокійна ситуація і
Росія стягує війська і як говорили
сьогодні що незрозуміло що буде зі
сторони білорусів в українську адресу А
зараз ще попитаємо людей Чому вони
сьогодні тут Добрий день ви в прямому
ефірі скажіть
не прийшли після Печерського районного
суду міста Києва ну сказати що пора
нашому президенту собирати вже свої
монетки і тікати тому що я
на все що ми залишаюся у крові правовій
державі і коли уже прийде час то він
буде сидіти і відповідати за це все тому
ми хоч цей проце
с думається і піде сам він має скласти
мандат і дати нормально розвиватися
нашій державі Тобто ви переконані що
мають бути дострокові вибори президента
звісно Ну ця людина не може нам керувати
не управляти І ви Верховну Раду також
мають бути дострокові вибори 100%. як
ставитесь до рішення по черту районного
суду міста Києва з приводу особистого
зобов'язання для 5-го президента України
Петра Порошенка ну
з яких кращих мало бути рішень ну
взагалі Моя думка вони мали його закрити
цю справу і відпустити все але дуже
добре що судді не пішли на такі жорстокі
неправові методи
кривосудя це не Посадили там чи якусь
заставу просто ну це саме м'яке м'яке
рішення яке я від них очікувала так тому
тому Ну це краще але мають закрити його
просто Дякуємо вам дуже І от як ми
сьогодні вже чули від людей що вони
вважають що якби не була така шалена
підтримка
як України Петра Порошенка то можливо
було би і інше рішення це рішення
називається таким як ми почули найбільш
м'яким яке можливо Добрий день ви в
прямому ефірі Скажіть будь ласка чому
сьогодні
і Яке ваше враження від рішення
Печерського суду
прийшли підтримати Петра Олексійовича
однозначно рішення Печерського суду
двояки таке бо Ну я сподівався що
Ну виправдають і все а так треба ще
чекати але Петро Олексійович знає що він
має підтримку і ну народ за правду
завжди вийде і зруйнувати досягнення
Революції гідності ніхто не дасть нікому
в тому числі зеленському
ставлення до того що було зранку ми
бачили коли забрали ці бочки коли били
людей Трошки так штовхали попадали жінки
розлилися західний газ ставлення вкрай
негативне ми не були на місці події в
Епіцентрі Ми якраз підходили але в
прямій трансляції бачили це ну люди були
обурені добре що вистачило розуму
правоохоронцям ну зупинити Ті дії і ну і
не продовжувати їх бо люди би просто
того не дозволили
того президента якщо будуть наля
апеляції і так далі однозначно так і я
думаю людей буде набагато більше я
сподіваюся що на тому все скінчиться
Зеленський зрозуміє що Ну в нього немає
в нього немає дальше шляху тиснути на
демократію і руйнувати під досягнення
які вже є народ цього не дозволить
Дякуємо вам дуже от поспілкувалися з
людьми і нагадаю пані Маруся
пані марубуку мені пані Маруся ми в
прямому
ефірі Яке ваше ставлення от почекаємо
пані Марусі пані Марусю Яке ваше
ставлення до рішення Печерського
районного суду міста Києва і чи будете
далі виходити за Петра Порошенка
я виходжу за демократію і я тут така не
одна
було два з половиною роки в цій країні
дуже жорстких ситуацій в яких кожен
лідер мав показати на що він здатен Я не
бачу щоб хтось показав себе таким
лідером який може дати спротив Росії
ніхто кроме Петра Олексійовича не
показала Я дуже зацікавлена в тому щоб
зараз коли ми обставилені російськими
військами хтось таки чинив цей спротив і
Хтось мав дипломатічні питання
вирішувати
професійно а не так як вони в нас
робилися два з половиною роки і в цьому
плані Петра Олексійовича теж поки що
ніхто не переплюнув тобто лідерівці
держав нам більше варіантів кого
підтримувати Якщо такі є Ну Напишіть
будь ласка в коментах
У нас є хотілось би розглянути але
ситуація що в нас більше нікого немає А
давайте когось іще пошукаємо не треба
нікого шукати коли в тоїй державі від
2,5 роки війна і кожен покаже на що він
здатен окрім того
були справі Петро Порошенко дивним чином
я бачу дивовижні збіги не стикувань і
відсутності конкретних доказів так само
як у своїй справі
від того моменту яким чином вони
намагались вручити це незаконно і не по
правилам так само як і в мене до певних
таких пробілів самій справі кримінальній
окрім того жодного немає прямого доказу
причетності жодного саме тому вони і
мають Зараз ці проблеми я все-таки за
е-е якісь закони в нашій країні
має вас перервати дякую вам дуже а я ж
передаю слово свої колезі Юлії вітовій
[музика]
Зараз ми далі продовжуємо спілкуватися з
людьми ми зустріли Олексія Гончаренка
Добрий день вам діліться ваше вас
діліться вашим сьогоднішнім настроєм все
ж таки це поки
[музика]
що чекає далі Ну по-перше настрій
святкових Христос хрещається ми маємо
свято
подивись що українці вийшли тисячі
українців вийшли захистити демократію в
нашій державі мова не про конкретну
фізичну особу мова не просто про Петра
Порошенка мова про те що якщо можна так
міжнародного доказу заарештувати п'ятого
президента то тоді можна будь-яку людину
знищити і навіть це ніхто не помітить
Так не можна і ми не можемо це дозволити
і люди вийшли і захистили не дали
можливість щоби заарештували Порошенка
не маючи на це жодних підстав
продемонстрували банковій зеленському що
Україна не Росія і він не зможе стати
Путіним Якби я йому цього не хотілося
тому що ці тисячі людей ніколи йому не
дадуть цього зробити це саме головне
тому так сьогодні в нас є перемога це не
велика перемога але це дуже важлива
перемога це знову ще раз свідчення того
що Україна - це Європа ми це довели і Я
вдячний кожній людині які проходили в
понеділок які прийшли сьогодні це тисячі
абсолютна свідомих людей в яких горять
очі тому що вони стоять за Україну і за
своє майбутнє і це дуже важливо і Ми
продемонстрували знов всьому світові що
в Україні є зріле громадянське
суспільство президент в нас там не
зрілий це правда А от люди в нас
абсолютно гідні і вони здатні відстояти
своє Скажіть будь ласка на вашу думку чи
вийде хтось все-таки з офісу президента
до людей Ой мені здається що Володимир
Руслан читав Зараз знаєте не переливки
він там дуже злякався і вже там
заховався в теплій бані десь там Ярмак і
могли водичкою розповідає не бійся не
бійся не так вже страшно не думаю що він
до нас вийде але він точно все це бачить
і він дуже хотів арештувати Порошенка ми
це бачили в понеділок але він не зміг це
зробити і це є надзвичайно важливо і
скажіть будь ласочка що таке Чи все ж
таки проїзд блінкіна вплинув на рішення
суду на вашу думку знаєте я хочу сказати
ми з повагою ставимо сьогодні прийшов
Штефан фюлі колишній єврокомісар не
Підтримати в суд Порошенка це дуже
важливо було багато заяв міжнародних це
дуже важливо але при всій повазі до пана
плівкіна це не плімкін вибори в
демократів в Україні а це українці
вибороли демократію в своїй державі і ми
Нікому її не віддамо нікому ми вдячні
всім хто нас підтримує і пану блін кіно
і Америка
нський ми британським європейським
колегам Але ми всі розуміємо що боронити
демократію в Україні це наше домашнє
завдання і ми з ним повірте мені
впораємося п Олексію Скажіть будь ласка
ось рішення про е-е особисте
зобов'язання яке сьогодні було прийнято
що очікував ви таке рішення взагалі Чи
влаштовує Воно вас І на вашу думку якісь
неї правильне рішення - це віддати цей
треш назад цим прокурорам і сказати що
вони робилися і хай забирають це геть бо
це абсолютно Нічого там немає а але
враховуючи що влада хотіла просто арешту
то звичайно Краще Вже так але треба
розуміти що зробила Влада вона
намагається обмежити опозицію
Порошенка забрали закордонний паспорт
йому не заборонено виїжджати за межі
Києва який Київської області це означає
обмеження його діяльності взагалі це
якась дурня є людина п'яте президент
якого знає весь світ в умовах коли Путін
стає стоїть зі зброєю біля наших воріт А
ви навпаки відправте його за кордон хай
він їде робить парламентську диплома
тію рахується з тими
кого він в багатьох замість цього влада
його боячість вона обмежує його
пересування діяльність це означає що
Зеленський більше ніж Путіна боїться
власного народу це дуже погано і нічим
добрим до нього це не закінчиться А ось
те що все ж таки вирішив пройтися від
володимирського від Печерського
районного суду сюди серед містян Києва
офісу президента що ви цим хотіли би
Можливо там якось щоб почув вас чи
президент саме чи можливо хтось саме на
банку Ось яка мета Сьогодні Цього маршу
наша мета дуже проста ще раз сказати
зеленському що є червоні лінії ми надамо
здати Україну ми надамо зробити
капітуляцію перед Путіним ми не дамо
стати на коліна йому перед Путіним і
поставити Україну на коліна і ми надамо
йому знищити демократію в Україні для
цього є суспільство він президент
України його обрали люди Я думав багато
хто з них вже так розчарований що хотіли
би повернути той момент три роки назад і
все було б інакше але сьогодні він
президент але він не цар тут і він не
може робити що завгодно
і для можна прокоментувати сьогоднішню
сутички з правоохоронців які сьогодні
вранці були чим вони були викликати
абсолютно провокація від влади
намагаючись показати начебто
агресивність протестувальників
Подивіться ну це абсолютно свідомі люди
які жодної не мають агресії які мають
гідність багато хто з цих людей то дуже
багато людей які воювали за Україну які
реально оборонили Україну Тому це
намагання показати начебто агресивність
протестувальників вона жалюгідна вона не
личить абсолютно і кидати правоохоронців
на власне це неправильно і Ми знов
продемонстрували ми мирні люди Ми з
мирним Протестом але Ми гідні люди Ми
свідомі люди і ми можемо боронити себе і
свої переконання на вашу думку ось те що
Порошенко Петро Порошенко забрали
закон зробили для того щоб унеможливити
е-е їздити там виконувати якогось
міжнародну діяльність
на це тема в них просто істерика Я їхав
в Сполучені Штати Америки значить щоб ви
розуміли я зустрівся з усіма
держдепартаментом Пентагон конгресмени
ну всі крім однієї людини посла України
в США вона ховалася від нашої делегації
вони робили все що ви з нами ніхто не
зустрів бояться Порошенка вони бояться
слова Правди їм здається що якщо ми
їдемо за кордон ми їдемо щось казати про
них та закордоном про них і так всі все
знають ми їдемо за кордон боронити
Україну захищати нашу державу ось для
чого ми їздимо за кордон але вони цього
не розуміють
п Олексіївська і будь ласка тоді ще таке
пан Порошенко вимагає притягнути до
відповідальності всіх причетних стосовно
сьогоднішнього побиття стосовно
сьогоднішнього получає яке відбулося
підпечерським судом чи вдасться це
зробити Ми будемо захищати всіх сьогодні
балуха е політв'язня людина якій був е
пройшов такі застінки Путіна його тут
били наші правоохоронці ну Як таке може
бути Звичайно що ми всьому цьому будемо
намагатися і вимагати розслідування і
добиватися Правди ми нікого не залишимо
і не покинемо повірте мені дякуємо
дякуємо за увагу нашим телеглядачам хочу
нагадати що нині Ми продовжуємо
знаходитись на банковій і продовжувати
спілкуватися з людьми їх сьогодні тут
справді дуже багато
я якийсь так і не взнала давайте
поспілкуємося з часом
Скажіть будь ласка що ви сьогодні тут
робите
ще сьогодні роблю я робив на барикаді
номер один на перекаті другий і на
барикаді третій не столи тоді Петра
Олексійовича відстоюємо і зараз від цієї
зеленої нетісті який сьогодні у вас
настрій
ну можна сказати нормальний тому що
обламалися вони ж хотіла арестувати
потравлюються наскільки я бачу у цьому
ще у аеропорту от не получилося ні 17-го
числа не вийшли ні нічого І сьогодні і
це мене в принципі радує Ну все ж таки
персональною особисто зобов'язання це не
решта все ж таки він може бути разом з
родиною Ну от
Ну не одна Женя і наскільки я чув від
пана Гончаренка у нього забрали
паспорт іностранний гурт от певні
обмеження але все ж таки він не зараз
Дякую дякую вам величезне за відповідь А
зараз я хочу передати слово свої колеги
Валентині мій
конкурс тобі слово
Юля Вітаю вас колеги Вітаю вас шановні
глядачі прямого Як бачите нині ми
перебуваємо на банковій на цій святковій
локації біля офісу президента України
про те у мітинги в учасників акції
настрій далеко не святковий чому давайте
розпитаємо у народного депутата від
фракції європейська Солідарність Миколи
княжицького п Микола Вітаю вас Розкажіть
будь ласка як ви взагалі можете оцінити
рішення Печерського суду сьогодні адже
про тотальну перемогу Я так розумію поки
мова не йдеться адже Петро Порошенко
нині буде змушений стати паспорта
закордонного він розповідав і про
закордонні турне про зустрічі
заплановані зокрема з представниками
НАТО Як ви можете оцінити рішення
сьогодні в Печерського районного суду це
по-перше це абсолютно ганебна справа І
абсолютно ганебне рішення Звичайно Це
рішення мало бути іншому вони хотіли
ув'язнити лідеропозиції але завдяки
сотні тисяч людей мільйонам людей які
підтримують європейську соліданські
Петра Порошенка особисто в усій Україні
вони цього не зробили вони просто
злякалися ці люди прийшли сюди під суд
ці люди прийшли в аеропорт зустрічати
Петра Олексійовича але те що вони
зробили це справді ганебно вони обмежили
його внутрі
шньо залишати Київ Вони намагаються
обмежити його міжнародну діяльність
вкрай ефективною Сьогодні він є одним з
основних політиків які виступають на
екранах е-е CNN як це було вчора інших
міжнародних каналів він проводить
зустрічі в європарламенті в багатьох
європейських країнах у Франції в
Німеччині спілкуються з американськими
сенатором все це робить Петро Порошенко
для того щоб об'єднати цивілізований
світ в нашій боротьбі з агресором який
хоче продовжити цю збройну агресію і всі
ми звичайно переживаємо за
нашими і Влада замість того щоб
об'єднатися чинить провокації проти
опозиції будує Режим Януковича пробую
його відновити намагається обмежити
літеру опозиції в його діях відкриває
ганебні справи які не мають під собою
жодних підстав Звичайно це повернення в
часи Януковича ми маємо зупинити і саме
це дозволить нам об'єднати міжнародну
коаліцію для захисту України
не вдалося заслухати рішення в понеділок
коли приїхали зокрема українці із
прифронтових міст з різних регіонів
країни бачили як це відбувалося наживо і
в аеропорті Жуляни потім під стінами
Печерського суду чому опісля Майже 6
годинної перерви та перебування в суді
вона речі і кімнаті вирішили все ж таки
оголосити рішення сьогодні чому 19 числа
та чи не пов'язано це на вашу думку З
приїздом блінкіна чи не відіграв він
певну участь у цьому Ну як сказав Петро
Порошенко хто до нас незалежний всі
звичайно посміялися коли почули цю
оцінку Ні ну вони хотіли
його сценарій коли вони побачи
ли міжнародної української підтримку
вони просто Злякалися і голови зламали
що зробити вони перенесли проголошення
рішення навіть не на наступний день а не
через день сподіваючись Що другий раз
люди не приїдуть але сьогодні до
Печерського суду прийшлось ще більше
людей ніж було позавчора і Влада думаючи
і переживаючи за своє майбутнє прийняла
таке половинчасте рішення з одного боку
обмежила лідером опозиції в праві
займатись політичною діяльністю але його
не ув'язнили під тиском і міжнародних
батареїв Але найголовніше - це українців
і українського суспільства пане Микола
як оцінюєте суспільне резонанс навколо
цієї справи бачили вже реакції наших
міжнародних партнерів зокрема посол
Британії В Україні ми Лінда сімонс
написала одразу що українцям Та взагалі
владі необхідно політикам об'єднуватися
нині у війні проти Росії та бути
надзвичайно об'єднаними а не провокувати
внутрішньодержавні конфлікти також
бачили оцінку саме європарламентарів
опора на російському телебаченні в одній
програмі в prime-time цілий час мусолили
цю тему з паном Порошенко та розповідали
Тобто можна сказати що інформацію
поширили максимально світом от ваша
думка щодо міжнародної реакції вона була
абсолютно нормально коли в демократичній
країні яка хоче бути членом НАТО
Європейського Союзу відбувається
політичні переслідування лідером
опозиції весь міжнародний світ
Та не чорним
іливає на нашу паралякану так би мовити
владу тому що Зеленський його партія
Вони ж не політичні діячі Вони люди які
тимчасово прийшли абсолютно випадково до
влади заради насправді заробляння грошей
заради того щоб служити олігархам і вони
не очікували такої реакції а коли вони
її побачили то вони як і цього слід було
очікувати перелякалися але цей переляк
людей які хочуть побувати побудувати
диктатуру він є оманливий тому всім вам
потрібно єднатися І дійсно захищати
демократію наостанок Скажіть будь ласка
які саме вимоги активістів тут на
банкові під стінами офісу президента Які
можливо основні меседжі ви почули от
саме що заявляють активістки Ми сюди
прийшли і політики і активісти для того
щоб ще раз сказати Володимир зеленському
що побудувати авторитаризм в Україні ми
надамо для того щоб йому сказати що йому
не треба відосіки постити і
текстики про спортивних зірок а справді
приділити серйозну увагу обороні для
того щоб сказати Йому ж треба негайно як
ми цього вимагаємо скликати позачергове
засідання Верховної Ради обговорити
надзвичайно складну безпеку ситуацію
зробити все для того щоб політикум в
Україні об'єднався і зробити все для
того щоб навколо нас і ми разом
об'єднали так само і Міжнародне
співтовариство Дякую вам пане Микола за
вашу думку та позицію що ж нині ми
поспілкувалися з народним депутатом від
фракції європейська Солідарність Миколи
княжицьким А нині я передаю слово свої
колезі Вікторії Максимові тож Віко
розказує як А в тебе ситуація
[музика]
Дякую колего от нині у нас така ситуація
що як ми бачимо все більше і більше
людей пройшли під офіс президента все
більше і більше людей пропускають і
зараз покажу як це все тут відбувається
зараз попрошу нашого оператора показати
наскільки багато людей ще стоять за
парканом і просто проходять обшуки від
поліціянтів аби потрапити на територію
під банкової і бачимо що все більше і
більше людей сходяться і можемо сказати
що коли хоча б більша частина сюди
пройде то я думаю що вже лунатимуть
гасла саме під офісом президента А зараз
ми запитаємо у людей Чому вони сьогодні
сюди прийшли Добрий день ви в прямому
ефірі Скажіть будь ласка чому сьогодні
прийшли на банкову А щоб показати що
Україна - це нелогія як сам Зеленський
ми прийшли за Порошенка і прийшли за
справедливе рішення суду І взагалі за
збере ження нашої України наші
суверенітета це наш такі вимоги і
підтримка Порошенку Як ви оцінюєте
рішення Печерського район
ного чаю і приїхав вже Ентоні блінке
вплинуло Звісно наш президент якщо він
наш він дає наш президент Він дуже
боягузливий теракт такий маленький тиран
але дуже боягузовий і та маса людей і
приїзд американця Звісно що вплинули на
рішення судів це 100% Наступного разу у
нас буде ще більше Зеленський
[музика]
на закордонних тере
нах України звісно блокує вони
спеціально це і робили аби він був
невиїзний і не міг виступати за Україну
на міжнародному рівні не міг доказувати
що Зеленський це не та влада як спасе
нашу Україну і поверне нам дійсно
достойні з нашої країни на міжнародному
рівні
тут Чернігівська область
ми проїхали спеціально підтримати
п'ятого образу звісно ми вже другий раз
позавчора ми були вистояли сутки Вони
думали що ми не будемо стояти ми будемо
стояти і Наступного разу нас ще більше
приїде погодів ще терпіти це зелене
недорозуміння дякуємо
[музика]
вам
ось ми бачимо що реально велика
кількість людей нині тут зібралася і тут
є і гучному цей і тут все чути власне і
зараз поспілкуємося ще з людьми Нехай
вони розкажуть нам свою думку
Добрий день
[музика]
котиться добре піде
мо Добрий день Можна вас на кілька слів
хотіли запитати чому ви сьогодні тут і
яка ваша позиція з приводу того яке
рішення щодо я такого президента України
ухвало Печерський районний суд
[музика]
звичайно
любов ніхто
партії України діє проти закону Як ви
сприйняли те що зранку були проти людей
застосувати був застосо
ваний це так далі через якийсь бочки як
можна так сказати
владу
а для того щоб вона нам захищала до речі
ви вважаєте таке рішення особисто
зобов'язання для п'ятого прецедента воно
досить як те хто каже м'яке і чи не
пов'язуєте ви це з цим що сьогодні до
України приїхав США Ентоні блін Можливо
але ти взагалі багато
повний судовий
так тому тут нема що говорити це тут на
поверхні
Дякуємо вам дуже скажіть а ви з Києва Чи
ви приїхали Я наразі зі Львова Зі Львова
аж проїхали підтримати п'ятого
президента
Дякуємо вам дуже І покажемо що тут
відбувається бачимо що певна кількість
людей залишається за городами певна
кількість людей залишається тут і
звичайно ж не обходиться і без таких
якихось інколи гострих слів на адресу
шостого президента України Володимира
Зеленського люди власне кажуть що
обурені І сьогодні і у понеділок вони
вийшли аби якщо підтри
мують працю в Україні підтримують закони
і права а я ж наразі передаю слово свої
колезі я ні про її
[музика]
подивимося так само під офісом
президента і я хочу зазначити що після
того як
сушена люди вирішили не просто розійтися
А піти саме на банкову 11 до офісу
президента аби висловити своє
невдоволення тим що взагалі відбувається
і зокрема що відбувалося сьогодні під
цінами Печерського районного суду а саме
акції з боку про правоохоронців Ну і
власне також сюди прийшли для того аби
сказати що вони не бояться і готові
відстоювати незалежність та
справедливість Ну і просто зараз ми
підемо і трошки поспілкуємося з людьми я
зазначу що зараз ось тут ви можете
бачити позаду мене прохід тут стоять
правоохоронці вони перевіряють людей по
черзі і пропускають невеличкими групами
Зараз підемо трошки будемо спілкуватися
з людьми власне зазначу що поки що їх
тут не дуже багато адже основна колона
знаходиться а саме ще за воротами їх
потрошку пропускають
ні власне Зараз трошки поспілкуємося
Добрий день Скажіть будь ласка
ви в прямому ефірі
добре до журналістів підійшли до своїх
колег Зараз трошки поспілкуємося з
людьми які ще тут є Добрий день А
розкажіть сьогодні вже винесено рішення
з приводу справи стосовно Петра
Порошенка чому вирішили після засідання
після закінчення піти сюди
Ми виграли бі Але ми не виграли війну Я
хочу сказати що ми прийшли сьогодні під
банку бо для того щоб показати
[музика]
нено оскільки остаточне рішення суду з
Петра Порошенка не боїться но ми
показуємо що ми будемо стояти на захисті
нашого лідера у разі чого Тому що судити
лідера опозиції по сфабрикованим справам
це пряме порушення демократії
встановлення адаптатури в країні
диктатуру ми в 14-му році вже бачили вже
досить а молодь уся тут через те що нам
цій країні жити і ми не хочемо жити в
країні де нам будуть наказувати повчати
бачимо що власне дуже багато молоді
сьогодні тут вони невдоволені тим що
нині відбувається Просто судове свавілля
судять лідера опозиції Ну і власне я
зазначу Що Сьогодні Петрові Порошенко
обрали запобіжний захід у вигляді
особистого зобов'язання йому в нього
також забрали закордонний паспорт а саме
це будуть оскаржувати його адвока
ти закордонних зустрічей зі своїми
колегами політи
ками Добрий день Розкажіть чому сьогодні
після засідання судового ви прийшли на
банкову
почув хто він такий що він шмаркля
зелене
і ворог України і посіпака путії всім
оцім нашим ворогам на
вашу думку ми ще не Перша наша зустріч
воно ж буде цепляться зубами це ж
карантин зубами буде цепляться за це
крісло буде ну ще буде творити Дякую
Отже бачимо що дійсно люди розуміють що
боротьба лише починається але всі готові
до неї всі готові боротися за опозицією
за свого лідера і за незалежну Україну А
нині ж я передаю слово своїй колезі Юлії
вікові
Яна Дякую за передачу слово Ми
продовжуємо знаходитися на вулиці
банковій під описом президента Будемо
продовжувати спілкуватися з людьми
нагадаю що після завершення суду люди
пішли від початку
студента Добрий день вам Дозвольте
поспілкуватися з Вами з яким
настроєм ви пройшли
з щастям з радостю те що ми не втрачаємо
Україну те що ми
відстоюємо її Те що
моїм моїм внукам я залишу державу які
які якою можна гордитись
протягнути до відповідальності винних на
вашу думку я так думаю що зараз ні тому
що ви бачите яка камарілія сидить отут
от на банковій а
по номерам ніхто не від злочину не втече
але може не зараз Згодом я так думаю
сьогодні суд досить
рішення Так скажіть будь ласка чи не
прийшов
на це кіно
Повторіть будь ласка
яке було
прийнято все на це приїзд самогонки
Я думаю вплинуло
саме страхом не лишньої влади страхом
просто страхом нинішньої влади і все
ваше життя
[музика]
люди продовжують скандувати А ми будемо
спілкуватися з ними далі Добрий день вам
Скажіть будь ласка з яким настроєм ви
сьогодні тут
важко перевагу
хотілося Куліша відвідати звісно але без
президента нам не дам поїсти
знаєте ці величезні почки все ж таки
вкрали на вашу думку чого це було
зроблено
в офісі президента зробити
[музика]
ой путінська політика ховатися за
спинами жінок дітей Скажіть будь ласка
на вашу думку що чекає нас далі це ж
лише малесенька перемога що буде далі
потрібно отримувати повну перемогу
потрібно отримувати
[музика]
немає зараз взагалі президента
повно командувачі перед
[музика]
потенційною новалою з
Росії вам потрібен головна командувач
зараз його взагалі немає
є лижник
[музика]
які найближчим часом Україну чекають
все-таки зміни
[музика]
мо
ми
вам
нашу свободу
[музика]
коза
Слава нації Україна
[музика]
!
»
[музика]
Ми хочемо збудувати для наших дітей і
для наших внуків разом Ми з сильними
разом ми йти в уда
[музика]
рним і неможливо якого вони кольору
і зелену ми це зробимо якщо
перед нами стоїть завдання врятувати
Україну брати і сестри зараз
бажаючі можуть пройти
офіс президента я котрі нагадую про те
що там є багато тимчасових споруд
картонних будиночків в яких знаходяться
тільки
Зеленський заховався за дітьми я нагадую
про те що миті тимчасові споруди ті
будиночки ми їх не чіпаємо вони повинні
залишитися в такому вигляді як вони є
зараз частина товариства може
повертатися на інститутську частину
товариства може йти
на сьогодні наша з вами зібрання брати і
сестри є завершений і дякувати Богу воно
завершилося
ство до зустрічі тому що ми так чи
інакше з вами рано чи пізно Побачимось
час не певний час тяжкий тому гуртуємось
готуємось брати і сестри
[музика]
його завжди напоготові зразу
все Дякую брати і сестри ну і з вами був
ваш незмінний голос Святослав Бойко
Дякую всім вам і до зустрічі